Hey, God, sorry, I didn't see you there. You got me off guard, I was just, um, I just really missed Sean and Jason right now. Feeling real, feeling real lonely out here in this cold open, I'm on my own. Oh my God, I promised myself I would cry. Not wouldn't cry, then I would cry, and I can't do it. Gosh dang it, alright, it's an all new smartness. Smart. Smart.
嘿，天哪，对不起，我没看到你在这。你把我弄得有点措手不及，我刚才，嗯，我刚才真的很想念肖恩和杰森。在这段冷开场里感觉真的，感觉真的好孤独，就我一个人。哦，天哪，我发誓我会哭的。不是不哭，而是会哭，但我却哭不出来。真该死，好吧，这是一个全新的“精明时刻”。精明。精明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
精明。精明。精明。精明。精明。精明。精明。精明。
Smart. Smart. Bless. Hi y'all. Hi y'all. Good evening. Hi, good evening. Very late. This is a very, very unusual smartness after dark.
精明。精明。保佑。大家好。大家好。大家晚上好。嗨，晚上好。非常晚。这是一个非常、非常不寻常的“深夜精明时刻”。
This is smartness after dark. Yeah, I mean, should we take a piece of clothing off maybe. Oh, let's see how it goes. I mean, doesn't that what usually happens after dark in my house? Okay, everyone's topless after six. No kidding. Am I the only one of my pajamas
这就是深夜精明。对啊，我是说，也许我们该脱件衣服什么的。哦，让我们看看情况再说。我是说，这不通常是我家深夜会发生的事情吗？好吧，六点以后大家都得光膀子。开玩笑吧。难道我是唯一一个穿着睡衣的人……
other than the baseball hat? No, I'm in my pajamas, but that doesn't change anything from our daytime recording. No, no, no, no, no. But JB, what's the earliest and all But JB, what's the earliest, and all jokes aside, what's the earliest you'll get in your jammies? If I'm not going out at all, I never get out of them. I'll be in it all day.
除了戴着棒球帽？不，我穿着睡衣，但这并不影响我们白天的录制。不，不，不，不，不。但是JB，最少……等等，JB，抛开玩笑不谈，你最早什么时候会换上睡衣？如果我完全不出门的话，我就绝不会脱下它。我会穿上一整天。
Although, and you're telling me, I smell like juicy, disgusting juice. No one knows. Wait, what's the quote? What does it usually say? I usually say you smell like dirty, disgusting juicy juice. What did you just say? Yeah, something like that.
虽然，你在跟我说，我闻起来像多汁、恶心的果汁。没人知道。等等，原话是什么？他通常怎么说？我通常说你闻起来像脏兮兮、恶心的多汁果汁。你刚刚说了什么？对，差不多是这样。
No, you usually smell like a chin chin. Yeah, that's true. This is true. But I mean, you always make fun of me because I, or what was it? I was wearing the same thing like all day long. You're like, you didn't take another shower? Yeah.
不，你通常闻起来像个Chin Chin。对，没错。这是真的。但我的意思是，你总是取笑我，因为我……或者那是什么？我一整天都穿着同一件衣服。你就说：“你没再洗个澡吗？”对。
Yeah. You're taking the same shower. You'll wear the same. Would you both get into today? Here we are at the end of the day. Do you feel like you used today correctly? Mm-hmm. What did you waste today? I do. I thought that I'd see you.
对。你洗的是同一个澡。你穿的也是同一套。你们两个今天都干了什么？我们迎来了这一天的尾声。你们觉得自己今天过得有意义吗？嗯。你们今天浪费了什么吗？我觉得有。我以为我会见到你。
I attacked the hill this morning. I took the kids to school, attacked the hill, didn't call either of you. I was on my journey, because I didn't want to get another impression of my breathless phone calls. And then... Were you zipped into your plastic sweatsuit? I was zipped into it. Your rubber bag. I'd love it if you actually had one of those. I'm weird.
我今天早上冲刺了一座小山。我送孩子们上学，冲刺了小山，没给你们俩打电话。我在进行我的旅程，因为我不想再给你们留下我对气喘吁吁的电话的印象。然后……你拉上了你的塑料运动服拉链吗？我拉上了。你的橡胶袋。如果你真的有那种东西，我可太喜欢了。我很奇怪。
I honestly, I haven't seen one of those since Rocky. It wasn't Rocky jogging in one of those. Yeah. He jogged and then then then it's some actor years later. Yes, and yes, I was just going to say Lawrence, Martin Lawrence. Martin Lawrence. Yeah. Ever that. Really. He had a job really long enough. And then and then I worked with Chappy this afternoon, we wrote for about four hours. So what does that look like, by the way, these writing sessions? Can I guess, are you, you're on a computer with him because he's over there in England, and he just sort of shares his screen with you, and you kind of watch him right. No. No.
说实话，自从《洛奇》之后我就没见过那种东西了。难道不是洛奇穿着那玩意儿慢跑吗？对。他慢跑，然后……然后几年后某个演员……是的，没错，我正要说是劳伦斯，马丁·劳伦斯。马丁·劳伦斯。对。曾经那样过。真的。他慢跑的时间真的够长。然后……然后我今天下午和查皮合作了，我们写了大约四个小时。顺便问一下，这种写作课程是什么样的？我来猜猜，你是在电脑上跟他连线，因为他在英国，然后他把屏幕共享给你，你就看着他写吗？不。不。
Wrong. Yeah. I just get. Can you tell the camera? Chappy typo, Chappy typo. Yeah, I can tell the camera. Two lines up. Yeah, you forgot the apostrophe right there.
猜错了。对。我只是……你能告诉镜头吗？查皮拼写错误，查皮拼写错误。对，我可以告诉镜头。往上两行。对，你刚才把撇号漏在那里了。
I, I, I just got back, we like about an hour ago from having a facial to answer your question. I treated myself. I haven't had one a long, long, long time. No, this is the kind where they, they pop.
我……我……我刚刚回来，为了回答你的问题，大约一个小时前我刚做完面部护理。我犒劳了自己一下。我好久、好久、好久没做过了。不，这是那种他们会……他们会挤的。
Okay, I don't know. Okay, well, I'm trying to long, long, long time. No, this is the kind where they, they pop. Okay, I don't know. Okay. Well, I'm trying to fucking, you know, my wife's very diligent about making sure that I get in there and get my facial once a year. Yeah. Are you more frequent than that, Sean? No, maybe two a year.
好吧，我不知道。好吧，嗯，我想……好久、好久、好久没做过了。不，这是那种他们会……他们会挤的。好吧，我不知道。好吧。嗯，我他妈的……你知道的，我太太对确保我去那儿做一年一次的面部护理非常上心。对。肖恩，你的频率比那高吗？没有，大概一年两次吧。
When's the last time you had your toes and fingers done? Years and years. No, you've had a manicure and a pedicure. No, not for years and years and years. Well, don've had a manicure and petty cure. No, not for years and years and years. Will don't lie. Last man, he petty. Man, he had a no, but I've had two facials in the last six weeks. Are you serious? Yeah. Yeah. Because he had some on camera work. Did you? No, yeah, but you know what? I haven't had one in at least five years before that. Okay. And let's This explains a lot.
你上一次修脚和做美甲是什么时候？好多年好多年了。不，你做过美甲和脚部护理。不，已经好多年好多年了。好吧，做过美甲和脚部护理。不，好多年好多年了。好吧，别撒谎。上次做美甲和脚部护理。不，不过我在过去六周里做过两次面部护理。你是认真的吗？对。对。因为他有一些镜头前的工作。是吗？不，对，但你知道吗？在此之前，我至少有五年没做过了。好吧。这……这解释了很多。
Yeah. It feels good though. Tell you what. I pass out. Yeah, me too. Yeah, I do too. Do you have one of those ugly wakeups when you're still like, oh my god. I totally do every time.
对。不过感觉挺好的。跟你说实话。我会昏睡过去。对，我也是。对，我也是。你有没有那种很难看的醒来方式，当你还觉得，哦，天哪。我每次都这样。
This is also relatable. I also had a massage recently when I, and, and, and we, I did a 90-minute massage. It's not that favorite. Everybody gets massages in the world. I don't get them all the time. And I had, and she levy, I was 90 minutes and she just kept me face down the full 90. And I was asleep. So I didn't know that I had it done like the flip over. And she was, and I fully did a, a dish woke up. And then my face had been in the donut, I'm facing down for 90 minutes. I look like I'd just been kicked in the face repeatedly. Yeah.
这也挺让人有共鸣的。我最近也做了一次按摩，我……我……我们，我做了90分钟的按摩。这倒不是什么最受欢迎的。世界上每个人都做按摩。我可不是一直都在做。我有一次，她让……我趴了整整90分钟。我睡着了。所以我不知道我已经做完了，比如翻身。然后她……我彻底地……醒了过来。然后我的脸一直埋在那个头枕洞里，趴了90分钟。我看起来就像被人反复踢了脸一样。对。
You know, our friend Justin Thoreau, you know, when he gets a massage for some weird reason, he likes to watch World War II documentaries. What are you talking about? That's not a bit. That's all he does when he gets a massage. So he'll put his face in the doughnut and he'll put his phone down on the floor and he'll just watch tanks and flame throwers. All kinds of carnage.
你知道我们的朋友贾斯汀·塞洛克斯吗？你知道的，当他去做按摩时，出于某种奇怪的原因，他喜欢看二战纪录片。你在说什么？这不是个段落。他按摩时看的就是这个。所以他会把脸埋进头枕里，把手机放在地板上，然后就看着坦克和火焰喷射器。各种各样的大屠杀。
Where's the relaxing part? You tell me, this is like, I don't know, this is a guy that flies, you know, transcontinental topless. So try to figure him out. Does he really? Yeah, he falls asleep on a plane. He can't sleep without a shirt on. With a shirt on, he can't sleep.
放松的部分在哪里？你告诉我，这就像是，我不知道，这是一个会穿着光膀子跨越大陆飞行的人，所以试着去理解他吧。他真的会这样吗？对，他在飞机上睡着了。他不穿衬衫就睡不着。穿着衬衫，他就睡不着。
So we've be sleeping on a plane or wherever he's sleeping, he's got to take a shirt off. That's just as gross as somebody putting their bare feet on the seat behind you on a plane. Like you know, JB, you just hit, you just hit the main vein of JB's disgust. What would be worse, walking around a hotel room without socks or shoes on or walking down the aisle way of a plane without a plane? Yeah, I'd say a plane plane for sure. Yeah, which is, which is a tight second.
所以我们在飞机上睡觉，或者无论他在哪里睡觉，他都得把衬衫脱掉。这就像有人把光脚丫搭在你身后飞机座位上一样恶心。就像你知道的，JB，你刚触碰到了……你刚触碰到了JB最恶心的痛点。什么更糟糕，在酒店房间里光着脚或不穿袜子走来走去，还是不穿鞋走在飞机的过道上？对，我绝对会说飞机过道。对，紧随其后的是……
Because you know, they don't, they don't like that. It's a cursory clean. They just go, ooh, okay, start you out in horror by when you go through the radar thing, you take your shoes off and you gotta put your socks there on the little foot outline thing and we'll have a hot socks have been from people all over the world.
因为你知道，他们才不会……他们才不会那样。这只是例行清洁。他们只会，哦，好吧，当你通过安检扫描时，恐怖就开始了，你得脱下鞋子，你得把袜子踩在那个小脚印图案上，而这些袜子可是来自世界各地的人穿过的。
And your hot sweaty feet have to go on exactly the same spot. Their hot sweaty feet just left. Oh, it's a fucking disaster. That's a great title for Simon. I love you, Doc. You know what, this is so good to hear you working off your long-term memory of what it's like going through an airport.
而你热乎乎、汗津津的脚必须踩在他们刚刚离开的那个一模一样的位置上。哦，这太他妈是一场灾难了。这给西蒙起个好名字。我爱你，Doc。你知道吗，听到你运用对机场经历的长期记忆，感觉真好。
And I always try to straddle those little pain outs. Sure. Sure. And like, I step on the inside of the outside and like, no, no, no, no, inside the line, sir. Yeah, you gotta be inside. It's like a fucking murder chalk outline, okay? You gotta be right inside the satellite and then they get me out of here.
我总是试图跨过那些小方块。当然。当然。就像，我踩在里面的外面，然后，不，不，不，不，踩在里面，先生。对，你得踩在里面。这就像是一个他妈的谋杀案粉笔轮廓，好吧？你得刚好踩在标记里面，然后他们让我离开这儿。
And then I gotta put them back in, then I put those hot socks back in my shoes. Now the shoes are ruined. Yeah. Why are the shoes ruined? They put the hot shoes? They put the hot shoes? You're transferring the germs. Yeah, and now they're dead to me.
然后我得把它们放回去，接着我把那些热乎乎的袜子塞回鞋子里。现在鞋子全毁了。对。为什么鞋子全毁了？他们把热鞋子……他们把热鞋子怎么了？你在传播细菌。对，现在它们对我来说死定了。
Jason, you know what, you're gonna hate? What is it? The rest of the world. Yeah. The rest of the world. This is what you get at seven o'clock at night. I know it's frankly, Bateman. Well, you know what, the else. You get a seven a.m. too. I tell you what else you get at seven p.m. Yeah, this is the heck. You get yourself a heck of a guest. There we go. Oh shit. Will's taking a sip. I took a sip to make sure that I'm, that I'm queued up. You know what I mean? And I'm all sort of, I got a nice voice.
杰森，你知道吗，你会讨厌什么？是什么？全世界。对。全世界。这就是你在晚上七点钟能得到的。我知道这坦白说，贝特曼。好吧，你知道还有什么吗。你早上七点也能得到。我告诉你晚上七点还能得到什么。对，这就是见鬼的。你能得到一个绝佳的嘉宾。这就对了。哦，操。威尔在喝水。我喝了一口来确保我……我准备好了。你知道我的意思吗？而且我整个人，我有一个好嗓子。
This guest better be fucking great, Arnad. This guest, you know this guest. And 720 at night. So this guest, okay, well let me ask you this, is how's a guest who's won a writer's guild of America award or a Grammy award? Grammy award. Great to, you got? Independent Spirit Award, a BAFTA, an Academy award. I apologize for my tone.
这个嘉宾最好他妈的棒极了，阿纳德。这个嘉宾，你认识这个嘉宾。而且是在晚上七点二十。所以这个嘉宾，好吧，那我问你这个，一个获得过美国编剧工会奖或格莱美奖的嘉宾怎么样？格莱美奖。太棒了，你懂的？独立精神奖、英国电影学院奖、奥斯卡奖。我为我的语气道歉。
Our tonight's guest is one, all those things, okay. So maybe you want to hold your seven PM anger back a little bit. That was Sean. Okay. That was Sean. Are they a Tony Shive and he got, you know what he is? He is a Tony, he's a Are they a Tony Shive and he got. You know what he is? He is a Tony.
我们今晚的嘉宾集齐了所有这些奖项，好吧。所以你也许想把你的七点钟怒火稍微收敛一点。那是肖恩。好吧。那是肖恩。他们是托尼奖……而且他得了，你知道他是什么吗？他是一个托尼奖……他们是托尼奖……而且他得了。你知道他是什么吗？他是一个托尼奖。
He's a Tony and an Emmy Shive and he got. He's been nominated for the Emmy. I don't know if he, a few times. I don't know if he's been nominated for a Tony, but I wouldn't be. I feel good to web you for this guest. He might get a webby. This guy, this guy does it all. He's a writer.
他是一个托尼奖和一个艾美奖得主，而且他得过。他曾获得过艾美奖提名。我不知道他是否……好几次。我不知道他是否获得过托尼奖，但我也不会……我为能请到这位嘉宾感到高兴。他甚至可能拿过威比奖。这家伙，这家伙什么都会。他是个编剧。
He's a director. He's a really funny performer, which I think people know because he's in a bunch of stuff that he directs. But I find him to be one of the funniest dudes that I know. He makes me laugh consistently, even though he's does some really serious stuff as well. We don't worry about what he does in the shadows. We're just worried about what he did with JoJo Rabbit. It's like a YTD. This is fully excused.
他是个导演。他是一个非常搞笑的表演者，我想人们都知道这点，因为他出演了他自己执导的好多作品。但我发现他是我认识的最搞笑的家伙之一。他总能让我开怀大笑，尽管他也做过一些非常严肃的工作。我们不用担心他在《吸血鬼生活》里做了什么。我们只关心他对《乔乔的兔子》做了什么。就像一部YTD。这完全可以原谅。
Polly excused. Don't get this. DANGER! Don't take a well done well. You're a very good, very good. I had this whole computer screen covered with this flapper paper that you told me to get. The time to get.
完全可以原谅。别拿这个……危险！别把这做得很完美。你非常棒，非常好。我让整个电脑屏幕都贴满了你叫我买的那种挡光纸。该买的时候。
How did it feel now that it's sort of This is the first reveal of you guys too. Wow, I love the mustache. Well, what do you think? It's fantastic. Thanks buddy. I was happy that we prepping for a role this whole time, the strike is on. And I'm disappointed.
现在感觉怎么样，当它有点……这也是你们俩的首次亮相。哇，我喜欢这个胡子。好吧，你觉得怎么样？太棒了。谢谢老兄。我很高兴我们一直在为一个角色做准备，而罢工开始了。而且我很失望。
I'm disappointed. Wait, didn't you guys just work together? Isn't there, didn't the movie come out? Didn't they work together? Well, I didn't mention it, but we do have a thank you, Sean, for the promotion, because Tyga and... Great, thank you for your show.
我很失望。等等，你们俩刚刚不是一起合作过吗？难道没有……电影不是刚上映吗？他们没合作过吗？好吧，我没提这事，但我们确实有……谢谢你，肖恩的宣传，因为泰卡和……太好了，谢谢你的节目。
Searchlight, light will love this Tyka's next film next goal wins is about to be released. I can't wait to see it Maybe at the time of this it is released and it's a great movie and it was made even better by some of the casting The trailer looks incredible. It does can't wait to see it. It's like look so Starlight you know, you said we just had done a movie together, completely forgot that. I know. I shot this movie so long ago,
探照灯影业会喜欢这个的，泰卡的新电影《下一球获胜》即将上映。我等不及要看了。也许在节目播出时它已经上映了，这是一部伟大的电影，而且由于一些演员的选择，它变得更好了。预告片看起来难以置信。确实如此，等不及要看了。看起来太……星光熠熠了，你知道，你刚才说我们刚刚一起拍了一部电影，我完全把这事给忘了。我知道。这部电影我拍了好久了，
and it's been so memorable performance, really. I know. I know. I know. By the way, it's all that shit on the other room floor. That's just the good stuff. Reminded it. We did.
而且真的是一次非常难忘的表演。我知道。我知道。我知道。顺便说一句，所有那些剪掉的废片。那可都是好东西。提醒一下。我们确实拍了。
We also did our flag means death, right around that same time together, which was, which is a series about pirates. It is. So just looking at the scoreboard, that's two for will zero for zero for Jason. Yeah. Don't worry. Listen, maybe when you're lucky, when you work with that guy, you won't remember you
差不多在那个时候，我们还一起合作了《我们的旗帜意味着死亡》，那是一部关于海盗的剧集。确实是。所以看看记分牌，威廉得两分，杰森得零分。是的。别担心。听着，也许当你走运的时候，当你和那家伙合作时，你也不会记得你……
having that at either. That would be exciting. Jason, I actually forgot to email you back about that other thing. Well, when I said I couldn't do to email you back about that other thing. Well, when I said I couldn't do the soccer movie, give it to Will. That you said me something. I wish. What did I say?
你也拥有过那段经历。那将令人兴奋。杰森，我其实忘了回你关于另一件事的邮件了。好吧，当我说了我不能……回你关于另一件事的邮件了。好吧，当我拒绝了那部足球电影时，把它给威尔。你跟我说过什么的。我希望如此。我都说了什么？
Did I send you something to look at? Maybe. So I'd be like that. You know you said me something. I don't remember things at all. Hey, where are you? Are you down? I just landed in L.A.
我有发什么给你看吗？也许吧。所以我才会那样。你知道你跟我说过什么的。我一点也记不起来了。嘿，你在哪？你降落了吗？我刚在洛杉矶降落。
This is why it's late, and I appreciate you guys doing this at this hour. Oh, we appreciate you. I just went through that airport experience and I'm exactly like you, Jason. I can't stand it. Do you still have the dirty socks on right now? Yeah, I do. I do.
这就是为什么这么晚，我很感激你们在这个时间做这件事。哦，我们也很感激你。我刚经历过那种机场经历，我跟你一模一样，杰森。我简直无法忍受。你现在还穿着那双脏袜子吗？对，我穿着。我穿着。
Straight from the airport. I don't want to touch it. Go burn them. But the thing, I kill my feet outwards, you know, when you stand on the edge. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Just put the pressure on the outside. I'm hoping to have less surface area touching the grid.
直接从机场来的。我不想碰它。去把它们烧了吧。但那件事，我把脚往外侧撇，你知道的，当你站在边缘的时候。对，对，对，对。只要把压力放在外侧。我希望有更少的表面积接触到那个网格。
Yeah. Yeah. Will, at what point in the the pressure on the outside. Hoping to have less surface area touching the grid. Yeah. Yeah. Will, at what point in the interview can we talk about JoJo Rabbit? Do you have a plan for this? Do you have a bunch of questions? Well, let's talk about, no, no, you know, we never have a plan.
对。对。威尔，在采访的哪个阶段……压力放在外侧。希望有更少的表面积接触到网格。对。对。威尔，在采访的哪个阶段我们可以聊聊《乔乔的兔子》？你对此有什么计划吗？你准备了一堆问题吗？好吧，我们来聊聊……不，不，你知道的，我们从来没有计划。
It's totally an apple. So we can talk about airports. Let's talk about JoJo Rabbit because if people haven't seen JoJo Rabbit, I heard you just fucking see it, I'm believe both. Right. Oh, sorry, I thought that's where you're going. It's the film that earned Tycat Academy Award for Best Adaptive Screenplay and film in
完全是即兴的。所以我们可以聊聊机场。我们来聊聊《乔乔的兔子》，因为如果人们还没看过《乔乔的兔子》，我听说你他妈的就得去看，我相信两边都是。对。哦，抱歉，我还以为你要往那儿扯呢。就是这部为泰卡赢得奥斯卡最佳改编剧本奖的电影，在这部电影里……
which you play Hitler. It's so funny. Yeah. You know, and take it easy, everybody. He's Jewish, okay? Take it easy. And also put that on the poster. Don't worry. He's Jewish. Take it Take it easy. And I should put that on the poster. Don't worry. He's
你扮演了希特勒。太搞笑了。对。你知道的，大家都放轻松点。他是犹太人，好吧？放轻松点。而且把这个印在海报上。别担心。他是犹太人。放轻松，放轻松。我应该把它印在海报上。别担心。他是……
Jewish. Take it easy. You should have been on the poster. But folks, if you haven't seen it, don't be an idiot and we longer get out there and what was it? Help your career? Three years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. 2019. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two 2019 actually yeah so take it actually walk us through that a little bit I'm curious because you adapted that from a book What was how did that go down that you were like oh man? This has to be a movie what what was that process like for you my mother read this book called Cajing Skies And she pitched it to me she said you should make this into a movie and the way she pitched the story to me I found so funny and And I thought, this is fantastic. And then I've read the book, and it was the least funny book I've read in a long time. And there was no imaginary Hitler in any of that stuff, but the way that she described what was going on in this world, I thought,
犹太人。放轻松。这本该印在海报上的。但是伙计们，如果你们还没看过，别当个笨蛋，赶紧去看看吧，那是……什么时候来着？对你的事业有帮助？三年。两年。两年。两年。两年。两年。两年。两年。两年。2019年，实际上是的。所以，实际上，带我们稍微回顾一下。我很感兴趣，因为你是从一本书改编的。那是怎么回事，让你觉得，哦，天哪？这必须拍成电影，对你来说那个过程是怎样的？我妈妈读了一本叫《笼中天空》的书。她把它推荐给我，她说你应该把它拍成电影，她向我推销这个故事的方式我发现太有趣了。
I'll go with her pitch. Anyway, and I added just those other elements to it, like Hitler. So what was it? It was a kid going to a Hitler youth camp. Yeah, it was about a little kid who wanted to be the best Nazi in the world. Very topical right now. And he tried... And then he got home. He gets home one day and he finds that his mother's hiding a girl in their attic, a Jewish girl in their attic, and he has an absolute meltdown.
我觉得，这太棒了。然后我读了这本书，这是我很久以来读过的最不有趣的书。而且里面根本没有虚构的希特勒之类的东西，但是她描述这个世界发生的事情的方式，我想……我还是顺着她的思路来吧。不管怎样，我只是在其中加入了一些其他的元素，比如希特勒。所以它讲的是什么？是一个孩子去参加希特勒青年团。对，讲的是一个小男孩想成为世界上最好的纳粹分子。现在非常应景。他试着……然后他回家了。有一天他回到家，发现他妈妈在阁楼里藏了一个女孩，一个犹太女孩在他们的阁楼里，他彻底精神崩溃了。
There's no idea what to do about this thing. Which I was here. Imagine this is like, you know, he's been taught that they're monsters with horns and, you know, devil towels and stuff. I mean, for people who haven't seen it, it's just so goddamn good. And it just, the plane lands at the end of this thing in a way
完全不知道该拿这事怎么办。我想象这就好像，你知道的，他一直被灌输说那些是长着角的怪物，还有魔鬼尾巴之类的话。我的意思是，对于没看过的观众来说，这部电影简直太棒了。而且最后收尾的方式……
that is so exciting and elegant and fun. And it's just, I don't know how you threaded that needle totally all the way through the film and then an even narrower one at the end and just drilled it. Thanks. It's true and and my question was so you did play Hitler were you always were you always going to play that part where you like I got to do this or did that how did that? No I never imagined I mean look I'm you know I'm brown and too good looking, some would say.
如此激动人心、优雅而有趣。我不知道你是怎么在整部电影中自始至终完美拿捏，最后又以一个更狭窄的角度收尾并精准命中的。谢谢。确实如此，我的问题是，你确实演了希特勒，你一开始就打算演这个角色吗？你是觉得“我必须得演这个”，还是……那是怎么回事？不，我从来没想过。你看，我是……你知道的，我是个棕色皮肤的人，而且长得太好看了，有些人会这么说。
You're very, very, very, very handsome. A few are, but we did put it out to a lot of actors and I don't even think they got to see the script. I think their agents immediately said there's a hard, no, it's a hard pass on this one. So is it easy pass? So then a few, and I went and made a few other movies I thought, when I was going to make this, it'll be one of those blacklist scripts that never gets off the blacklist. And then searchlight, who made this soccer film with us,
你非常、非常、非常、非常帅。少数人是这样，但我们确实把剧本发给了很多演员，而且我甚至不觉得他们有机会看到剧本。我想他们的经纪人立刻就说，这是一个绝对的“不”，这个坚决不能接。所以是个轻松的拒绝？然后一些人……我拍了其他几部电影，我想，当我打算拍这部电影时，它会成为那种永远无法脱离黑名单的黑名单剧本。然后是探照灯影业，他们和我们一起制作了这部足球电影，
they said to me, we really want to make this film, but only if you play Hitler. And see, these guys, I mean, consistently through multiple administrations have been like one of the most courageous, tasteful companies in all of their game. I can't imagine a bunch of other companies that would have said, yes, what was the pitch process like when you went in there about like, you know, exactly what it was like. Well, but I mean, did you, did you, did you have your agent sort of, you know, soften the
他们对我说，我们真的很想拍这部电影，但前提是你必须演希特勒。你看，这些家伙，我是说，在多届管理层更迭中，他们一直都是这个行业中最有勇气、最有品味的公司之一。我想象不出还有哪家公司会说“好”。当时你进去推销时的过程是怎样的，关于……你知道的，那具体是什么样的。好吧，但是我的意思是，你……你……你有没有让你的经纪人稍微……你知道的，铺垫一下，
ground a little bit and say, he's gonna pitch your Hitler film, but it's not like what you, I mean, was there any warning at all? No, no, no, no. And we went through multiple studios and started with, okay, it's about a kid growing up in World War II, who's in the Hitler youth. And then the eyes would glaze over, you see them fidget uncomfortably in their seat, and I would sort of just trail off from there. So you just know instantly that it's not for them. But like from jump, though, the way that you play and introduce Hitler is just like,
稍微缓和一下语气，说“他要推销一部关于希特勒的电影，但它不是你想的那种……我的意思是，当时有任何警告吗？”没有，没有，没有，没有。我们跑了好几个电影公司，从这样开始：“好的，讲的是一个二战中长大的孩子，他是希特勒青年团成员。”然后他们的眼神就会变得呆滞，你会看到他们在座位上不安地扭动，然后我就会从那里开始语无伦次。所以你瞬间就知道这不适合他们。但从一开始，你扮演和介绍希特勒的方式就让人觉得……
oh, I'm in. I'm wearing great hands. That, only this is going, they're not going to ask me to fall in love with Hitler. They're not going to, like, I think it was helpful that you didn't look, you'd terribly like the classic Hitler. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think it was helpful that you didn't look, you'd terribly like the classic hit. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I also think what helped with not having a big star play, that role as a would've overshadowed everything else,
哦，我懂了。我有很好的帮手。只有这样，他们才不会要求我爱上希特勒。他们不会……我觉得有这样一个事实很有帮助，那就是你看上去并不太像经典的希特勒。对，对，对。我觉得有这样一个事实很有帮助，那就是你看上去并不太像经典的希特勒。对，对，对。我也觉得，没有找一个大明星来演那个角色，这很有帮助，否则会喧宾夺主，
the whole story itself would've been the... Gussie, the Tom Cruise hit the movie. Right. So Tom Cruise passed on it. Well, we had some news. Okay. It was just so, so great. It's so good. And so, so you do that.
整个故事本身就会变成……就像汤姆·克鲁斯的希特勒电影一样。对。所以汤姆·克鲁斯拒绝了。好吧，我们有一些消息。好吧。这真是太、太棒了。太好了。所以，你拍了那个。
I mean, this is like, it's such a, um, yeah, it's Jason said. I mean, it's, it, and it sounds like very sort of high brow. And it is, but at the same time, it's very accessible. And it, and it's just so, I don't know, there's something really, and it's playful and it's real, and there's a lot going on, and it really hits you in so many different ways. And I like a film like that, where you can't describe it as...
我的意思是，这就像是一个……是的，正如杰森所说。我的意思是，这……听起来非常阳春白雪。确实如此，但与此同时它又非常平易近人。而且它……我不知道，这里面有些非常……它既俏皮又真实，里面有很多东西，它真的从很多不同的方面触动了你。我喜欢这样的电影，你不能把它简单归类为……
It's not really a comedy, it's not really a drama. It's sort of... Yeah. Trids that little path in between the things. And, you know, I needed to make it, you know, we've all seen great Holocaust films, you know, Schindler's list and so forth. And I don't think I could have made one of those
它不完全是一部喜剧，也不是一部纯粹的剧情片。它有点……对。走的是介于两者之间的小路。而且，你知道的，我需要拍它，我们都看过伟大的大屠杀电影，你知道的，《辛德勒的名单》等等。我不认为我能拍出那种……
very serious films. And we've seen so many of them. And I think if you want to get a message across or talk about something like heavy like that, you've got to find different ways of telling that story. And one way which I think is the most important way of telling stories like that is using humor. But you weren't even asked for a laugh. You were simply just in this wonderful kids perspective.
非常严肃的电影。而且我们已经看过太多那种电影了。我想如果你想传达一个信息，或者谈论像这样沉重的话题，你必须找到不同的方式来讲述那个故事。而我认为讲述这类故事最重要的一种方式就是运用幽默。但你甚至不是为了博取笑声。你只是单纯地处于这个奇妙孩子的视角。
And that just allowed you so much latitude. I think it wasn't really Hitler. It wasn't really Hitler's is an imaginary Hitler from the mind of an 11 year old boy. So you can only know what an 11 year old knows. Right. Why is it buffooned and an idiot? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's great. I love when like Jews tackle that topic. It's just beautiful. Like Mel Brooks always you, you know, Spielberg, just I love the dichotomy of them telling the story from their point of view, you know, from their artistic point of view. You don't want to see Hitler movie from me.
这给了你极大的创作自由。我觉得这其实不是真正的希特勒。这并不是真正的希特勒，而是一个11岁男孩脑海中虚构的希特勒。所以你只能知道一个11岁孩子所知道的事情。对。为什么它显得滑稽而白痴？对。对。对。太棒了。我喜欢犹太人探讨这个话题的时候。简直太美妙了。就像梅尔·布鲁克斯一直以来做的，你知道的，斯皮尔伯格，我就是喜欢他们从自己的视角、从艺术视角来讲述故事的那种二分法。你才不想看我拍的希特勒电影呢。
No, no, no, not at all, not with a mustache like that. Okay. He never got this one. And we will be right back. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard, you can listen to episodes of this very show, AdFree, and one week early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right, all your favorite smartless episodes can be heard on Amazon Music AdFree,
不，不，不，一点也不，顶着那样的小胡子可不行。好吧。他可从来没有这个。我们马上回来。Smartless的粉丝们注意啦。你们听说过吗，你可以通过Amazon Music的Prime会员资格，在一周前提前收听这个节目的剧集，而且完全没有广告？没错，你所有最喜欢的Smartless剧集都可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听，
and you'll always be the one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all you can listen to any of your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates, and Just Jack and Will, early, and ad-free too. They also have favorites like the daily part might take an up first all without any ads. You know what this means? Uninterrupted listening, so no more cliff hangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast
并且你总是能第一时间听到我们的新剧集，这样你就可以向朋友们炫耀了。但这还不是全部，你还可以提前且无广告地收听任何其他你喜欢的节目，比如，我不知道，比如《Bad Dates》和《Just Jack and Will》。他们还有像《The Daily》、《Up First》这样受欢迎的节目，全都没有任何广告。你知道这意味着什么吗？不间断的收听，所以再也没有悬念了。Amazon Music提供最多无广告的顶级播客，
so we know they definitely have something for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. Till listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com, slash smartlist, that's Amazon.com, slash smartlist, or download the Amazon Music App. It's just that easy. This message is brought to you by our sponsor, Visit Florida.
所以我们知道他们绝对有适合你的内容。而且这已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。要立即收听，你只需要访问Amazon.com/smartless，也就是Amazon.com/smartless，或者下载Amazon Music App。就是这么简单。本期节目由我们的赞助商Visit Florida为您呈现。
Why not escape to Paradise on your next vacation? Check out Naples, Marco Island, and the Everglades, Florida's Paradise Coast. Dip into turquoise waters on the over 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline. From the secluded Key Whadon Island to Luxury Beachfront Resorts, there's a spot for everyone.
为什么不在你的下一个假期逃离到天堂去呢？来看看那不勒斯、马可岛和大沼泽地，佛罗里达的天堂海岸吧。在超过30英里 pristine 墨西哥湾海岸线的绿松石般的水域中畅游。从隐秘的基惠登岛到豪华的海滨度假村，这里有一个适合所有人的地方。
Outdoor adventurers, brace yourself for an exhilarating playground of endless mangroves. I like those estuaries and shorelines to experience plus boating, fishing, diving and an abundance of golf courses. Singing a little pampering, diving to opulence with upscale boutique's art galleries and world-class spa's nestled in Naples.
户外冒险家们，准备好迎接一个由无尽红树林组成的令人兴奋的游乐场吧。我喜欢那些河口和海岸线，还有划船、钓鱼、潜水和丰富的高尔夫球场。想要享受一点 pampering，那就沉浸在奢华之中吧，那不勒斯错落有致的高档精品店、艺术画廊和世界级水疗中心正等着你。
Nestled in Naples is the name of my biography. I mean, come on, what's more relaxing than lounging amid cypress trees to the soothing sounds of golf breezes? If food's more your thing, you can save a fusion of flavors with fresh from the golf, seafood and globally inspired cuisine at Top Natch restaurants.
“坐落在那不勒斯”是我自传的名字。我的意思是，拜托，还有什么比在柏树林中伴随着海风的舒缓声音闲逛更放松的呢？如果美食更合你的胃口，你可以在顶级餐厅里品尝融合了来自墨西哥湾的新鲜海鲜和全球灵感的美食。
The dining scene on Paradise Coast is a feast for the senses, for the finest of everything Florida has to offer, only Paradise will do. Visit paradisecoast.com slash smartless to start planning your trip today! This episode has brought to you in part by WeWork, the world's leading flexible space provider. Who doesn't like working flexibility, right? I'm in my pajamas recording these ads right now.
天堂海岸的餐饮场景是一场感官盛宴，为了体验佛罗里达所能提供的最好的东西，只有天堂才是唯一的选择。访问paradisecoast.com/smartless开始规划你的旅程吧！本节目部分内容由 WeWork 提供，WeWork 是全球领先的灵活办公空间提供商。谁不喜欢工作的灵活性呢，对吧？我现在就穿着睡衣在录这些广告呢。
Don't you wish you had visual as well as audio? But that's beside the point. I can imagine the flexibility that WeWork offers is fantastic. You can come and go as you please. It's your space. It's significant to you and your needs. It seems like a dream come true for anybody that wants a flexible work schedule.
难道你不希望既有视觉又有音频吗？但那都不是重点。我能想象 WeWork 提供的灵活性简直太棒了。你可以随意进出。这是你的空间。它对你和你的需求具有重要意义。对于任何想要灵活工作时间的人来说，这简直就像美梦成真。
The world of work has changed whether fully remote in office or somewhere in between. People are looking for spaces that inspire, connect, and help with productivity and collaboration to give their businesses an edge. Enter, we work. Their solutions are inherently flexible and built for all the ways people work today.
无论你是完全远程办公、在办公室办公，还是介于两者之间，工作世界都已经发生了改变。人们都在寻找能够激发灵感、建立连接并有助于提高生产力和协作的空间，以为他们的企业带来优势。这时候，WeWork 就登场了。他们的解决方案天生具有灵活性，专为当今人们的所有工作方式而打造。
We work as solutions for individuals and for companies no matter what the size, from co-working memberships to hundreds of work spaces around the world, and dedicated office space for teams of all sizes to collaborate. Their space is foster collaboration and connectivity, bring teams together in person and work alongside some of the most innovative companies today.
无论是个体还是各种规模的公司，WeWork 都有相应的解决方案，从联合办公会员资格到遍布全球的数百个办公空间，再到适合各种规模团队协作的专属办公空间。他们的空间促进了协作和连接，将团队汇聚在一起进行面对面工作，并与当今最具创新力的公司并肩工作。
Get the flexibility your team needs with monthly memberships without the long term commitments that can change just as easily as your needs do. WeWork makes it easy. Get into a turnkey office with furniture, wifi, and other amenities ready to use on day one without all the upfront costs. Interested in finding out more visit WeWork.com slash smartless. Be sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. That's WeWork.com slash SmartLess. We work. And now back to the show.
获取你团队所需的灵活性，通过按月付费的会员资格，无需长期承诺，这些承诺可以像你的需求一样轻易改变。WeWork 让这一切变得简单。入住配备家具、wifi 和其他随时可用设施的即开即用办公室，第一天即可投入使用，而无需支付所有前期费用。有兴趣了解更多信息吗？请访问 WeWork.com/smartless。请务必使用我们的网址，以便他们知道是我们介绍你来的。网址是 WeWork.com/SmartLess。We work。现在回到节目中。
Hey, let me ask you this. You touched on it, Tyken. It's one of the things I said sort of in my rough intro, but you are such a super hilarious dude, just as a person. And I think that one of your superpowers is using, you always find a way to make everything you do fun and funny. Like, even, by the way, even our flag means death, which is kind of a love story between these two guys. And it's, but it's a pirate show, but it's really a comedy, but I mean, it's more of a
嘿，让我问你这个。泰卡，你刚刚提到了这一点。这是我在简短的开场白中提到的一点，但你真的是一个超级搞笑的家伙，作为一个普通人来说。而且我认为你的超能力之一就是运用幽默，你总能找到方法让你做的每一件事都变得有趣和好笑。比如，顺便说一句，甚至连《我们的旗帜意味着死亡》也是如此，那基本上是这两个家伙之间的爱情故事。而且它是一部海盗剧，但它真的是一部喜剧，不过我的意思是，它可能比你的许多其他作品更像是一部喜剧，但你总是拥有如此棒的幽默元素。我知道你在现实生活中也运用它。这也是我喜欢的一点。我会被那些对A自己、B无论一个主题有多严肃，都总是能通过幽默来切入、来削弱它的人所吸引。当你考虑创作内容时，这有多重要？
comedy probably than a lot of your other stuff, but you always have such great elements of humor. And I know that you use it in your real life, too. And it's one of the things that I like. I'm drawn to other people who can have a sense of humor about A themselves and B that no matter what how serious a subject is, that there's always a way to access it through humor, to sort of undercut it. And how important is that to you when you're thinking about making stuff?
因为你其实并不喜欢过于一本正经，对吧？不，好吧，来自新西兰的我们有着非常灵敏的“装腔作势雷达”。当我们看到某些东西让我们觉得有点尴尬时，我们就会尽量避免去做它。而且我认为我看过所有最好的喜剧都具备这种光明与黑暗的完美融合。这正是生活每一天的写照。它充满了悲剧与喜剧。这就是我喜欢的电影。我所做的事情也希望将这两种元素完美融合。你在成长过程中有哪些喜爱的作品？有哪些作为灵感来源的最喜欢的电影？
Because you don't get really like to earnest really? No, well coming from New Zealand we have a very sensitive cheesiness meter. When we see something we feel like it's a bit cringey, we try and avoid doing it. And I think all the best comedies I've ever seen have just had that real mix of light and dark. And that's what life is every day. It's full of tragedy and comedy. And that's what I like my films. And the things I do to just have a mix of both those things. What were some of those growing up that you loved? One of your favorite movies that were inspirations?
在成长过程中，我的最爱，你知道的，非常年轻的时候是黑色幽默，还有英国电视喜剧，比如《金龟车》（Faulty Towers）之类的，那真的是我的最爱之一。真正的纯喜剧，但他们拍得非常高效、非常出色。我觉得《奇爱博士》
Well, growing up, I mean, the things I loved, you know, really young black out of, and like British TV comedies, like Faulty Towers and things like that, which was, you know, one of my favorite. Real straight comedies, but they did it really efficiently and really well. That, you know, I think Strangelov
是拍得最好的喜剧之一。我喜欢《毕业生》。我看过的最好的喜剧之一是《飞行总动员》，你也是其中的一部分。当时它上映的时候，我想，我的生活改变了。这是我一生中看过最好笑的节目。对，雷蒙德和布雷特……你知道的，雷蒙德，我还和斯特尔一起写作，现在经常和他合作。《时光大盗》我们正在拍一部电视剧。我们正把它拍成电视剧。对。哦，是吗。那太棒了。我太喜欢了。我们依然一起合作写很多东西，
is one of the best comedies that's been made. I love the graduate. One of the best comedies I've ever seen is Final of the Concords, which you were a part of. And I thought when that came out, I was like, well, my life has changed. That's the funniest show I've ever seen in my life. Yeah, Jermaine and Brett have been tested in, you know, Jermaine, I write with Still and it makes off with him a lot now. Time bandits were making a TV. We're turning that into a TV show. Yeah. Oh, you are. That's awesome. I love that. We still do a lot of writing together,
而且他依然是我认为最好的编剧。哦，不。你是怎么……对，我想知道，你和……在图书馆里看到彼此，我想我们立刻就对彼此产生了一种反感，就凭我们长相的那种方式，然后花了大约两三两个月的时间，我们才开始合得来，然后……那会是一个最好的朋友。操。伴随着你所有的成功、艺术赞誉以及所有这些，现在我确信你可以
and he's still, I think, the best writer. Oh, no. How did you, yeah, I want to know, how did you and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, show thing and we saw each other in the library and I think instantly took a dislike to each other just the best of way we look and then it took about two or three months before we started to get on and and there there would be a best made citizens. Fuck with with all of your success and artistic accolades and all that stuff, you now I'm sure can
像《乔乔的兔子的》这样的推销就不会那么难了，因为人们信任你。你发现，当你刚开始职业生涯时，你拥有那种带有“装腔作势雷达”的幽默感。换句话说，你不会为了让观众感到超级舒服、像这个国家、好莱坞、许多掌权者要求你做的那样去走极端，去手把手照顾任何人。
a pitch like JoJo Rabbit would not be quite as difficult because people trust you. How did you find, when you started your career, you had that sense of humor that was in the cheese meter. In other words, you wouldn't go to the extremes to make an audience feel super comfortable, hold anybody's hand like this country, Hollywood, a lot of the people in charge, will ask you to do.
他们不会真正给你保持这种边缘的自由。你是如何度过那个时期，并且没有直接爆粗口说“管他呢，这些人根本不懂我在搞什么”的？我一直都在这么想，现在也是。我觉得在这里太好笑了。你必须解释一切。所有制作出来的东西。你只想说，让我给你们看点素材吧，但他们从来不这样。
They won't really give you the latitude to kind of keep the edges of that. How did you get through that period and not just hit fuck it? These people don't get what I've got. I did think that all the time and still do. I think it's so funny here. You have to explain everything. Everything that gets made. You want to just say, just let me show you some footage, but they're never like that.
他们不会给你真正的自由去保留那些边缘的东西。你是怎么度过那段时期，而没有直接说去他的？这些人根本不理解我所拥有的一切。我当时一直这么想，现在也这么想。我觉得这里太搞笑了。你必须解释一切。制作出来的每一样东西。你只想说，让我给你们看一些素材吧，但他们从来不这样。
Yeah, but I mean, even to the audience, you have to explain everything throughout the story, every beat of the way. And so there are no surprises. There's no putting trusting the filmmaker to deliver the story in their own way. But I would just come to, I'd make film in New Zealand, I'd come here and show it at the Sundance or something and no one would see it. And then studios would say, do you want to do this film and be, you know, some, I'm not going to say horrible, but it's like a wrong calm or something and no one would see it and then studios would say, do you want to do this film and be a, you know, some, I'm not going to say horrible, but, you know, like it's like a wrong calm or something that wasn't really up my, um, out my alley. And then I'd think, nah, I'll go back to New Zealand and make another thing. And
对，但我的意思是，甚至对观众来说，你必须在整个故事中解释所有事情，故事的每一个节拍都要解释。所以根本没有惊喜。没有那种去信任电影制作人以他们自己的方式讲述故事的余地。但我会去新西兰拍电影，然后来这里在圣丹斯电影节之类的活动上首映，结果根本没人看。然后电影公司会说，你想拍这部电影吗，然后是，你知道的，某种，我不是说很糟糕，但就像是一部糟糕的爱情喜剧什么的，根本没人看，接着电影公司就会说，你想拍这部电影吗，是个，你知道的，某种，我不是说很糟糕，但你知道的，就像是一部糟糕的爱情喜剧什么的，其实不太合我的，嗯，不太合我的胃口。然后我想，算了，我还是回新西兰再拍一部别的吧。然后
I just kept doing that about four or five times until, uh, finally I did. And then what we're doing in the shadows was really the one that kind of, I think had more attraction, um, in the States, even though really the one that kind of I think had more attraction In the States even there was still a kind of small cult issue, but it was that HBO? No, it was that there was a film and then we turned that into a show their Marvel asked me to come in and pitch it on thought Yeah, well you did you did Well, I'm for the wilder people in between that. Yeah, yeah, I'm for the world of people and that I don't know how these films did actually. I don't really remember. Are you getting checks?
我差不多就这么重复了四五次，直到，呃，最后我真的拍了。然后《吸血鬼生活》那部电影，我觉得它才真正开始在，嗯，在美国引起更多关注，尽管，即使它真的开始在，我觉得它在美国引起了更多关注，尽管它仍然带有一种小型邪典电影的色彩，但那是HBO的剧吗？不，那是当时有一部电影，然后我们把那部电影改编成了一部剧，接着漫威让我去参加会议并推销这个创意，我觉得，好吧，你在中间拍了《追捕野蛮人》，对吧。对，对，对，还有中间的《追捕野蛮人》，我不知道这些电影票房到底怎么样。我其实记不清了。你现在还在收版税支票吗？
You're getting a lot of checks in the mail. You know, all the checks. I think that's what he's checking. But I was gonna say, so then you do, but you do that stuff. You know, it's funny, we were working, like I mean, Steph and Tyke goes, we have worked together before it.
你正在源源不断地收到支票。你知道的，所有的支票。我想他就是在查这个。但我想说的是，所以你拍了，但你确实拍了那些东西。你知道的，这很有趣，我们之前合作过，我是说，斯蒂芬和塔伊卡，我们之前合作过。
And at this point, he had made two or three films in New Zealand. Okay, so he was like a legitimate filmmaker. And like he said, like you had, you'd open it, Sundance, at least twice, I think, and whatever. And he'd done this video. Sean, I think Sean's in it too, isn't he? Is Sean in it? Maybe not.
而此时，他在新西兰已经拍了两三部电影了。好吧，所以他就像是一个真正的电影制作人了。就像他说的，你至少两次在圣丹斯电影节开幕，我想，诸如此类。而且他拍过这个视频。肖恩，我觉得肖恩也在里面，对吧？肖恩在里面吗？也许没有吧。
We did for like an upfront, like a... It was for the Super Bowl. Super Bowl for NBC. If the NBC and it was going through all the shows on NBC, and it was the brotherhood of man, like, song from their musical, and they cut it all the different shows. How to succeed? And it did a verse or a couple of lines from the show.
我们拍过一个类似 upfront 的活动，就像一个……那是为超级碗拍的。NBC的超级碗广告。它串联了NBC所有的节目，那是他们音乐剧里的《人类兄弟》这首歌，他们把这首歌剪辑进不同的节目里。《如何成功》？它用了那部剧里的一段歌词或几句台词。
And it cut to me and Maya and Christina Applegate and Maya Rudolph and me. And Taggy goes, we have work together. And he shows me that. Yeah, I'm pretty. That's how it was. Was it in that? Yeah, it was. It was in that Donald Trump.
然后画面切到了我和玛雅、克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特、玛雅·鲁道夫还有我。塔伊卡说，我们合作过。然后他给我看那个。对，我很漂亮。当时就是这样的。你在那个里面吗？对，你在。你在那个唐纳德·特朗普的里。
It was a direct. I directed. I directed Trump. Really? Did you have a set of specifications that you have in your YouTube? Yeah, there was a piece of paper with a list of demands. Like, is like, the way that he likes to be lit. The height of the camera?
那是一个直接的。我执导的。我执导了特朗普。真的吗？你有一套拍摄规格的要求吗，就像你在YouTube上那种？对，有一张写着一长串要求的纸。比如，像是他喜欢的光照方式。摄像机的高度？
The height of the camera? Exactly. It had to be a certain height to make him look a little thinner. And yet, I think it had like a sort of whatever the pantone of orange was that he had to be appear as on screen. Wow. Wow.
摄像机的高度？没错。必须在一个特定的高度，好让他看起来稍微瘦一点。还有，我觉得上面还规定了某种他必须呈现在银幕上的橙色潘通色号。哇。哇。
It was sort of like a makeup person who was also his ego booster. So she would touch him up and say, oh Mr. Trump, oh Mr. Trump, you're so nice. Oh, yeah. Wait, was I in that? Were you in that? I don't know, maybe.
那感觉就像有一个化妆师，她同时也是他的情绪抚慰师。所以她会给他补妆，然后说，噢，特朗普先生，噢，特朗普先生，你真好。噢，对。等等，我在那里面吗？你在里面吗？我不知道，也许吧。
I don't know if you were in the reboot. I don't know, I don't know if you were in the promo. But I was like, but it's so funny. So here's Tyke like fucking like, it's not like he discovered talent late in his life. Like he had it. And but he's coming to America and they're offering him rom comes and he's like, now, and he'll make a couple bucks doing some video shit for people like for the Super Bowl. And then he fucks off back to New Zealand and to make his like indies and do what he
我不知道你有没有参演那个重制版。我不知道，我不知道你有没有参演那个宣传片。但我就觉得，这太搞笑了吧。所以你看塔伊卡就像个混蛋一样，这可不是说他在人生晚期才发现自己的才华。他一直都有。而且他来到美国，他们找他拍浪漫喜剧，而他却说，不要，他会帮别人拍点视频烂片赚点小钱，比如为超级碗拍片。然后他又滚回新西兰去拍他的独立电影，做他想做的事情。
wants. And what made you think that, you know, Marvel is so incredible at doing, at doing their, their thing. I mean, they've got a product that is just incredible. It is, made this industry twice as healthy as it's ever been. But I think you, one should and does and needs to adhere to a certain, um, the parameters, the parameters of the like, needs to adhere to a certain The parameters the parameters of like because that audience expects a certain boxes to be checked What made you think that your incredibly unique perspective on things would be a fit for something that you would probably agree It needs to stay inside a certain a certain boundary. Jason. That's wonderful question. I thank you Yeah, really close zero. Thank you. Is it a wonderful question? Yeah, thank you. I'm glad you are that's wonderful question. I think you
是什么让你觉得，你知道的，漫威在制作、在制作他们自己的东西方面是如此不可思议。我的意思是，他们拥有一个产品，简直不可思议。它确实让这个行业的健康程度达到了空前绝后的两倍。但我觉得，一个人应该、也确实、并且需要遵循某种，嗯，条条框框，某种规则，比如需要遵循某种，条条框框，就像因为观众期望满足某些特定的条条框框。是什么让你觉得，你那极其独特的视角会适合这样一个你可能会同意的东西，它需要呆在某种特定的界限之内。杰森。这是一个绝佳的问题。我谢谢你。对，简直毫无建树。谢谢。这是一个绝佳的问题吗？对，谢谢。我很高兴你是，这是一个绝佳的问题。我觉得你
Zero thank is a wonderful question. Yeah, thank you. I'm glad you are thank you Will. Did you hear all that? I didn't know I said it's a wonderful yeah, a lot of still a lot of compliments I'm asking in the glove the question to be on still really I'd get such a hard hitting so late to it would be our so articulate. I have another one. Hey To watch you to watch you suck Marvel's dick for so long, it's gonna be a treat. I took it all. Did you say you did take it all? Yeah, right down to the cubes.
毫无建树却是个绝佳的问题。对，谢谢。我很高兴你是，谢谢你，威尔。你都听到了吗？我刚才不知道我说了什么，我说是绝佳的，对，依然是一堆奉承话。我问这个问题本来是为了恭维，结果还是显得那么尖锐，那么直白，又那么口齿伶俐。我还有一个。嘿。看着你，看着你舔漫威的屁股这么久，这绝对是一种享受。我全盘接受了。你刚才说你全盘接受了？对，连骨头渣都不剩。
Let's get the answer now. Okay. Oh my gosh. Oh my god. Jason watched a skateboard in this free time. Oh, Fuck it. What happened to me? You know what?
我们现在就来听答案。好的。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。杰森竟然在闲暇时间看滑板。哦，见鬼。我怎么了？你知道吗？
I had no interest in doing one of those films. It wasn't on my whole plan of my career and all to it. But I was poor and I just had a second child. And I thought, you know what? This would be a great opportunity to feed these children. Or do it my dad did. Go ahead. Continue. I'm still doing my answer.
我对拍那种电影毫无兴趣。这根本不在我整个职业生涯的规划之内。但我当时很穷，而且我刚有了第二个孩子。我想，你知道吗？这绝对是个喂饱这几个孩子的绝佳机会。或者像我爸爸那样做。说吧。继续。我还在回答呢。
No, no. Yeah. Yeah. Hang. Okay. So then they called and they said, do you want to do this? And Thor was probably the face that was probably the least popular franchise. It was the, I had never read Thor comics when I was a kid.
不，不。对，对。等等。好吧。然后他们打电话来问，你想拍这个吗？雷神当时可能是一个最不受欢迎的特许经营项目。它是，我小时候从来没读过雷神漫画。
That was the comic I picked up. Oh. And then I thought, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I never read Thor comics when I was a kid. That was the comic I picked up and said, oh, but then I thought, and then I just researched on it. And I read one full comic, or still 18 pages of how long that I was still baffled by this character. And I thought, well, you know, I can bring to this. Let me know when it comes to comics. I mean, red is a stretch. Okay, go ahead, sorry.
那是唯一一本我拿起来读的漫画。哦。然后我想，而且，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我从来没读过雷神漫画。那是唯一一本我拿起来读的漫画，然后我想，后来我对此做了调研。我读了一整本漫画，或者说还有18页，我当时对这个角色依然感到一头雾水。我想，好吧，我知道，我可以给这个角色带来什么。等一下，说到漫画，我的意思是，读过简直是个勉强的说法。好吧，你继续，抱歉。
I'm going to look that. It looked dead. I flipped through, you know, and then pitched myself. I thought the only thing that I could bring is, I'm, you know, it's a character. It's like just looking at Thor as a character in Luke, yeah, he's like a billionaire lives in space. And, you know, he's got these just,
我去查了查那个。看起来死气沉沉的。我翻了翻，然后向他们推销了自己。我觉得我能带来的唯一东西就是，我，你知道的，这是一个角色。就像只是把雷神当作一个生活在太空里的亿万富翁来看待，对，他就像是个，
who looks ridiculous and that was sort of the end. I was like, well, this is highlight that. He's like a rich kid who, and I pitched that he's a bit like you and me Jason, that he hates germs. Right. And, you know, that didn't scare the shit out of them.
看起来荒谬绝伦，然后差不多就这样了。我就想，好吧，那就放大这一点。他就像是一个富二代，我当时推销说，他有点像你和我，杰森，他有洁癖。对。而且，你知道的，这可把他们吓得够呛。
I think there was no place left to go with that thing. Right, right, right. I was like, you felt like, I thought, wow, they called me in. This was really the bottom of the barrel. But Figgy has taken a nice swings on it. He has taken great. Right. I'm starting with Favreau, right? And then I mean, like,
我觉得那个项目当时已经山穷水尽了。对，对，对。我就觉得，你当时的感觉是，我心想，哇，他们竟然打电话找我。这绝对是落魄到谷底了。但费奇确实在这上面放手一搏了。他真的放手一搏了。对。从费儒开始，对吧？然后我的意思是，
and Kenneth Brana and Chloe Zhao and the Rousseau's. I guess it has been directors that have been outside of the box, but they know what they're good at, right? They're good at keeping everyone in their lane and making sure that they don't veer off into something else that doesn't feel marvel. So they bring people into a good story and making great characters and like, you know, bring something unique and then they'll keep it within the marvel. And you obviously had a great experience
还有肯尼思·布拉纳、赵婷和罗素兄弟。我想确实有一些跳出常规的导演，但他们很清楚自己擅长什么，对吧？他们擅长让每个人各司其职，确保他们不会偏离轨道去搞一些不符合漫威风格的东西。所以他们把人才吸纳进来讲述好故事，塑造优秀的角色，并且，你知道的，带来独特的东西，然后他们会把这一切控制在漫威的框架内。而你显然有着极好的体验，
because you went back for one. Yeah, yeah, I'm a bit... But it is true, like I remember, we have friends of ours who are doing another, one of these, I won't name it, but it's a series of movies that takes place in space. And they went off a little bit, I think, feared a little bit off the plan and ended up not working out because they had too many ideas that were outside of Marvel though.
因为你又回去拍了一部。对，对，我有点……但确实如此，就像我记得，我们有一些朋友正在拍另一部，其中一部这种类型的电影，我不会点名，但这是一系列发生在太空的电影。他们稍微偏离了一点，我觉得，稍微有点偏离计划，结果最后没能成功，因为他们有太多不属于漫威的想法。
No, no, no, I didn't say it was Marvel. I said it's a different, a different thing. But it was outside of the playbook a little bit, right? And so that it made them nervous because they got a lot of staggers, they're property and they got a lot of stag. So when they hired you, though, Tyka, I mean, again, knowing. The fans hated it by the way. They hated the, I was doing it. They hated Thor. No, the fact that I was doing it when I was running on the first one. And they're like, who's this guy? He's going to be like, no, but they fucking, they fucking end up loving it. My kids who are big Marvel fans, like my son
不，不，不，我没说是漫威。我说的是一个不同的，不同的东西。但它确实有点偏离剧本对吧？所以这让他们感到紧张，因为他们有很多资产，他们拥有很多资产。所以当他们雇佣你的时候，塔伊卡，我的意思是，再次声明，明知。顺便说一句，粉丝们恨死这个了。他们恨我接手这个项目。他们恨雷神。不，我是说当我接手第一部的时候，他们讨厌我接手。他们就像是，这家伙是谁？他会把电影拍成什么样？不，但他们他妈的，他们最后还是爱上了这部电影。我的孩子们都是漫威的超级粉丝，比如我儿子
Abel still to this day. When I told him that you were on the show tonight, he was like, wait, he's on the show tonight because he loves fucking Thor. So much. He's an idiot though. He's not in it. He's a funny fucking kid. He's not a, he's not a, he's not a, he's not a, dollar like you. Wait, Tyka, you get a compliment of Archi, you got to. When you hear, when you hear that about seven, this is the seven o'clock vision. We're going to throw out your guess. Babes 45 minutes past gummy hour. And he's not starting to shake.
阿贝尔直到今天依然如此。当我告诉他你今晚要来节目时，他脱口而出，什么？他今晚要上节目？因为他他妈的太爱雷神了。爱得深沉。但他是个白痴。他没来。他是个搞笑的混蛋。他可不是个，他不是个，他可不是个，像你这样的摇钱树。等等，塔伊卡，你得到了阿尔奇的赞美，你得。当你听到，当你听到关于七点钟这个愿景的时候。我们要抛弃你的嘉宾了。距离软糖时间已经过去45分钟了。而且他还没有开始颤抖。
And he's got the fight. It is not pleasant. Man, no, let him in. A man is going to, Texan been saying, you take that coming and 50 minutes later, you can come in house. She lived it on the front staff. I don't know. Top of the mailbox.
他的斗志昂扬。这可真不好受。伙计，不，让他进来吧。一个人会，泰克一直在说，你吃下那颗软糖，15分钟后，你就能进屋了。她当时就住在前台。我不知道。信箱顶上。
I was, I put the key next to the key. I take out places outside, waiting for it to kick in and then it's just a scratch. Coming on. Not a bang at the door. Yeah. And she's looking at her watch. She's like, $30, $ Oh, coming on. No, no, no. It's not a bang at the goal. Yeah. And she's looking at her watch. She's like, 30, 29, 28. Thank you.
我，我把钥匙放在钥匙旁边。塔伊卡在外面等着药效发作，然后他就只是抓挠门。敲门进来。不是砰砰砸门。对。然后她看着她的手表。她心想，30，29，28。谢谢。
Tyka, when you hear that, that fans, like you said, were maybe heavy. OK. Next question. The, the, the, the, almost little that you know, spit today. And then I have to ask about Mandalorian because I'm a massive, massive, massive, massive fan of that series.
塔伊卡，当你听到那些粉丝，就像你说的，可能很不爽。好吧。下一个问题。那个，那个，那个，几乎可以说是今天吐露出的微末之言。然后我必须问关于《曼达洛人》的问题，因为我是这部剧的超级、超级、超级、超级粉丝。
And so, Scottie and my husband, and how did you get Mandalorian? And how, by the way, and you voiced the droid, right? The IG 11? I do it all. And I'm like, John, so fat, right?
所以，还有我的丈夫斯科蒂，你是怎么接下《曼达洛人》的？还有，顺便问一下，你给那个机器人配音了对吧？就是IG-11？全都是我配的。我说，琼，太胖了吧，对吧？
What did he voiced? Sean? The droid. The IG 11. Sorry, what's a serial number on the right? Yeah, I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I make sure to make sure to have that on the top of your head. Yeah.
他给谁配音了？肖恩？那个机器人。IG-11。抱歉，那个机器人的序列号是什么？对，我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我确保把这个号码时刻记在脑子里。对。
Fuck it. This is how you landed Scotty. I always Yeah. Hey, you and I do. I'm going to put you when you your headstone when you die your grave so it's just going to be blank. Just to be nothing. Not even a date. Just no, it's so sorry. It'll say I apologize. Yeah gonna be nothing, not even a date. No, that's so sorry. It'll say I apologize. Yeah, it fucking nothing. So John said,
见鬼。这就是你拿下斯科蒂的方式。我总是，对。嘿，你和我。我要把这个刻在你的墓碑上，当你死后，你的墓碑将是一片空白。上面什么都没有。甚至连日期都没有。不，太抱歉了。上面会写着：我道歉。对，他妈的什么都没有。所以琼说，
Anyway, IG 11, people walk by, oh that's shiny. Well, IG 11, who show on the nose based on IG 88, that's correct. Wow, which is something I found out when I did the Mandalorian. Did that floer you as much as it's flooring me? What you're about to say, Fabro, picked you up and said, He picked me up. I was at the standing on Coney, picked me up, said,
不管怎样，IG-11，人们走过去说，哦，真闪亮。好吧，IG-11，根据IG-88改进而来的机器人，对吧？哇，这是我拍《曼达洛人》时才发现的事。这有没有把你震撼到，就像它现在震撼我一样？你刚才要说的是，费儒把你接去了，他说，他把我接走了。我当时正站在科尼岛，他把我接走，说：
Come, kid, come and do an episode of Mandalorian. I went down, this is the first time I've used that volume thing, but the TV screen's all in a big circle Yeah, we shot most of the show on that And he said come and do this this thing and it was great Because I didn't have to write it and do things just turn up and direct and it was awesome And he was there to help and the first day I was directing 75 stormtroopers. Oh wow standing a big giant stormtrooper battle. That was so cool. Oh fucking incredible
来吧，孩子，来拍一集《曼达洛人》。我去了，这是我第一次使用那个“魔方”虚拟制片技术，就是那个所有电视屏幕围成一个大圆圈的摄影棚。对，我们剧里大部分镜头都是在那上面拍的。他说，来拍这个东西吧，这太棒了。因为我不用写剧本，也不用干别的，只要出现并导演就行了，简直酷毙了。而且他在那里帮忙，我第一天就要导演75个暴风兵。哦，哇！站在一个巨大无比的暴风兵战场里。太酷了。简直酷毙了！
Oh my god. It is cool And by the way, it's good that you had a guy like Favre we like he's a friend of the show and we like him a lot Wow, Stan, a big giant storm tree, but battle. That's so cool. Just fucking incredible. Oh my god. By the way, it's good that you had a guy like Favreau. We like, he's a friend of the show, and we like him a lot. Love that giant Favreau. Yeah, same year. And I'm sure he was fucking helpful as shit, because he's a cool dude.
哦，天哪。这确实很酷。顺便说一句，你能有费儒这样的搭档真不错，他是我们节目的老朋友，我们都很喜欢他。哇，站在一个巨大无比的暴风兵战场里。太酷了。简直酷毙了！哦，天哪。顺便说一句，你能有费儒这样的搭档真不错，他是我们节目的老朋友，我们都很喜欢他。真喜欢那个巨大的费儒。对，同感。而且我敢肯定他肯定帮了大忙，因为他是个超酷的家伙。
Yeah. Taker, why, so why did you just fly into LA, and where were you? I went to Scotland, because I was hanging out in Scotland. And so just hanging out. Airbnb, at the special little pop-up places you can stay. I don't know if you heard about this, but they made Shrek's swamp with Shrek's house, a full replica of Shrek's tree and the house inside it, and everything is exactly like the move, the bed table. Rita is...
对。塔伊卡，为什么，所以你为什么突然飞去洛杉矶，你之前在哪儿？我去了苏格兰，因为我当时在苏格兰闲逛。就只是闲逛。爱彼迎，住在那种你可以体验的特殊小民宿里。我不知道你有没有听说过这个，他们把史莱克的沼泽地和史莱克的房子做成了一个完美的复制品，包括史莱克的树屋和里面的房子，一切都跟电影里一模一样，床头柜。丽塔她……
Your wife, Rita. My wife, yeah, amazing. So she booked us and we went and stayed at the Shrek. Hold on. Then we drove around Scotland and we dressed up. She made it, she bought costumes. Oh, I can't keep it right. We dressed up as Shrek and Princess Fiona.
你的妻子，丽塔。我的妻子，对，太棒了。所以她预订了这个地方，我们就去史莱克的树屋住了。等等。然后我们在苏格兰到处开车兜风，还盛装打扮。她准备的，她买了很多戏服。哦，我可不能把它说漏嘴。我们打扮成史莱克和菲奥娜公主。
She did some photos and stuff. There goes. What are you doing? Your free time question. Wait a second. Jason, the disgust of Jason's face. I just can't have a chance. Can I have 20 minutes of the interview real quick?
她拍了好多照片之类的。瞧他。你在干什么？你的“闲暇时间”问题。等一下。杰森，杰森脸上的嫌弃。我简直没法插话。我能有20分钟的时间来采访吗？
So you are married to your datinger. We don't. And, all right, so you are married to, you were dating her. We don't worry. And now, and now- I'm writing a single song right now. We're married. And now you're married. Yeah.
所以你娶了你的约会对象。我们没有。好吧，所以你娶了，你之前在跟她约会。我们不担心。现在，现在——我现在正在创作一首单曲。我们结婚了。而现在你们结婚了。对。
Did you know that she was such a fan of Shrek before you put a ring on her finger? No, no, you don't know that. So she's a big Shrek fan such that you went ahead and bought yourself a couple of first class tickets all the way over to Scotland. And you stayed in a little grasshopper. Yeah. And it was just part of the trip. There was just one fun thing we got to do.
在你给她戴上戒指之前，你知道她这么喜欢史莱克吗？不，不，你不知道。所以她是个超级史莱克迷，以至于你直接给自己买了两张直飞苏格兰的头等舱机票。然后你们住进了一个绿色的小屋。对。这只是旅行的一部分。这只是我们可以做的众多趣事之一。
You get that's fun, I guess. And then we drove around Scotland. We went hang out and look at the castle. That's pretty cool. I guess that's pretty cool. Now, if they had, now Sean, don't lie, if they had a place like this Airbnb that was Star Wars themed, would you take Scotty to, for his birthday surprise? Yeah. Without a doubt.
我觉得这挺有意思的。然后我们在苏格兰到处兜风。我们去闲逛，参观城堡。这挺酷的。我觉得这挺酷的。现在，如果他们有，肖恩，别撒谎，如果有一个像这样的爱彼迎民宿是以星球大战为主题的，你会带斯科蒂去那里给他一个生日惊喜吗？会。毫无疑问。
Yeah. Would you fly all the way to Scotland for it? Do you love him that much? Probably not. Would you go to space for it? It could exist in space. You wouldn't. Well, space is fast.
会。你会为此专门飞到苏格兰去吗？你这么爱他吗？可能不会。你会为此去太空吗？这可以在太空里存在。你才不会呢。好吧，太空太广阔了。
Would you like to go to space? Sean, absolutely. Don't you? Would you? No, honestly not. Absolutely. Now, I played golf today with Michael Strahan, who told me that he went up into that Jeff Bezos rocker thing, and I would do that.
你想去太空吗？肖恩，绝对想。你不想吗？你想吗？不，老实说，真不想。绝对想。今天我和迈克尔·斯特拉汉一起打高尔夫球，他告诉我他坐过杰夫·贝索斯的那个火箭飞船去过太空，如果是那个的话我会去的。
You would do that? Absolutely. Now, I just... I think, would you go to space? Yeah, I'd go to space. If I had a long. Oh, great question. Just a couple minutes.
你会去那个？绝对会。现在，我只是……我想，你会去太空吗？会，我会去太空。如果我有很长的时间。哦，好问题。只要几分钟。
I mean, what we... That's just a couple minutes. That Bezos thinks a couple minutes. I mean, what we... That's just a couple minutes. That baseless thing's a couple minutes. I just don't want to do anything that when I land the euphoria is relief because I got away with something. I feel like, you know, I just... I shouldn't be doing things that I get away with anymore. Well, that's how we feel about our careers.
我的意思是，我们……那只需要几分钟。贝索斯的那个东西只需要几分钟。我的意思是，我们……那只需要几分钟。贝索斯的那个玩意儿只需要几分钟。我只是不想做那种当我着陆时，感到的不是兴奋而是如释重负的事，因为我侥幸逃过了一劫。我觉得，你知道，我……我再也不应该去做那种只能靠侥幸逃过一劫的事情了。好吧，这就是我们对我们职业生涯的看法。
Yeah, that's true. Jason's like one of those dogs. You know, they have those colors and they set up the perimeter. And the perimeter is the golf club at his house. Okay. And if he goes any further, if I can shock some and it keeps him, you know, I would say. But Jay, it's a once in a lifetime thing that you could just experience the view of space and the weightlessness and like, you can't ever always love the weightlessness, Jay. Come't ever oh he's love the weightlessness Jake
对，没错。杰森就像那种狗。你知道的，它们脖子上戴着那种电子项圈，然后设定好活动范围。而这个范围就是他家的高尔夫球场。好吧。如果他再走远一点，如果我电击一下就能让他退回来，你知道的，我会这么说。但是，杰伊，这是一生只有一次的体验，你可以亲眼领略太空的风景和失重感，而且，你不可能总是喜欢失重感的，杰伊。不可能哦，他太喜欢失重感了，杰伊。
You know what you know what you know what you actually you end up getting very bloated up there Do you think so? Yeah, you know I know so you see no shots of the astronaut say it's really everybody you're taking away from the astronaut From talking to people in spaces. They look bloated man little too bloated little too But in the hair all stands up. I'm kidding. You know, I lean into all this stuff. I don't care about the germs. Scotland sounds great with this threat thing. And let's just get a parachute on me and get a plane going. This is all for bits. Yeah, I would love it would be great. I was just now thinking about Scotland. I was thinking about JB in like medieval times. Oh, and like people were like ripping, ripping, you know, ripping legs off of chickens and stuff
你知道吗，你知道吗，你知道吗，其实你到了那上面整个人会变得非常浮肿。你觉得呢？对，我知道，我太知道了。你看那些宇航员的照片，根本没有一个是正常的，每个人，你在跟那些去过太空的人聊天时得到的反馈是，他们看起来都肿了，老兄。有点过于浮肿了，稍微有点，不过头发倒是全都竖起来了。开玩笑的。你知道的，我这人什么都愿意尝试。我才不在乎什么细菌呢。有史莱克这个主题的苏格兰听起来真棒。赶紧给我套上降落伞，找架飞机出发吧。这全都是开玩笑的。对，我很乐意，那一定棒极了。我刚才在想苏格兰。我在想中世纪时期的JB。哦，还有人们在用餐时就像是，在疯狂撕扯，疯狂撕扯，你知道的，撕扯着鸡腿之类的东西，
at the meal and just, you know, biting into it and like, you know, just washing those hands. Damn. Castle with nobodies had that an invented socks really yet. No plumbing. No plumbing, no bath. The toilet paper. Oh. We'll be right back. Thanks to Amazon for their support with their low prices and huge selection, Amazon wants to help you share joy this holiday season.
然后直接咬上一大口，你知道的，甚至都不洗手。该死。没有一个人发明袜子的城堡。还没有下水道。没有下水道，没有浴缸。还有卫生纸。哦。我们马上回来。感谢亚马逊对我们的支持，凭借其低廉的价格和海量的选择，亚马逊希望在这个节日季帮你分享快乐。
And as we all know, the holidays are all about these joyful moments. I remember just a week ago, through Amazon, I ordered a little bracelet with all the planets on it because I'm a little bit of a sci-fi nerd. And guess what, I got two of them. And guess who the other person is that I gave it to. Scotty, so guess what, we both have them.
正如我们所知，节日全都是关于这些充满欢乐的时刻。我记得就在一周前，通过亚马逊，我订购了一个印有所有行星的小手链，因为我有点科幻迷属性。你猜怎么着，我收到了两个。你猜另一个人是谁，我把另一个送给了她。斯科蒂，所以你猜怎么着，我们俩都有一个。
And guess what was shared? Joy, tremendous joy between two people that love each other that now have planet beads on their wrists. It's pretty cool. And it's these types of moments that Amazon can help you create during the holidays, however you share joy, make it happen with holiday deals at Amazon.
你猜分享了什么？快乐，两个相爱的人手腕上都戴着行星串珠，他们之间洋溢着巨大的快乐。这真的很酷。而正是这种类型的时刻，亚马逊可以在节日期间帮你创造，无论你如何分享快乐，通过亚马逊的节日特惠让它成为现实。
Thank you to Sonos for supporting this episode. Elevate your audio experience to a whole new level with Sonos ARC, the premium smart sound bar that transcends ordinary listening. Arc was designed from the inside out for incredibly clear sound and rich bass, then fine-tuned by Oscar and Grammy-winning producers, mixers, and artists. True play tuning software further enhances your listening experience by optimizing Arc's sound for the unique acoustics of the room. Feel the immersive power of cinematic sound as Sonos arc unleashes crystal clear
感谢Sonos对本期节目的支持。使用Sonos Arc将你的音频体验提升到一个全新的水平，这是一款超越普通聆听体验的高端智能条形音箱。Arc从内到外专为无比清晰的声音和丰富的低音而设计，并经过奥斯卡和格莱美获奖制作人、混音师和艺术家的微调。Trueplay调音软件通过针对房间独特的声学特性优化Arc的声音，进一步提升你的聆听体验。当Sonos Arc释放出水晶般清晰的
room-filling sound with Dolby Atmos. When the TV is off-stream music podcast smart list, the radio, audio books, and more using the new Sonos app Apple Airplay 2 or guess what, your voice. So me in this house for me and Scotty, we have Sonos in every single room in our house and we just got the Aero 100. It's pretty cool. When we go in the backyard and we're sitting around we have a little tiny fireplace back there and we just use the Sonos Aero 100 and it's hooked up to our phone. We can play all of our favorite music but it sounds so much better with Sonos. Head over to Sonos.com and hooked up to our phone. We can play all of our favorite music, but it sounds so much better with Sonos.
充满房间的声音以及杜比全景声时，感受电影级音效的沉浸式震撼力量。当电视关闭时，你可以通过全新的Sonos应用程序、Apple AirPlay 2或者，你猜怎么着，你的声音来播放音乐、播客、智能列表、电台、有声读物等等。所以对我家里来说，对于我和斯科蒂，我们家里的每一个房间都有Sonos，我们刚刚入手了Era 100。这真的很酷。当我们去后院围坐在一起时，后院有一个小小的火炉，我们就用Sonos Era 100，它连接着我们的手机。我们可以播放所有最喜欢的音乐，用Sonos播放出来的声音简直好听太多了。前往Sonos.com，并将其连接到我们的手机。我们可以播放所有最喜欢的音乐，用Sonos播放出来的声音简直好听太多了。
Head over to Sonos.com and enjoy up to 25% off select products now through November 27th or while supplies last. Smartless listener, let me tell you a little bit about the Defender 110. You're up for any challenge that comes your way. The Defender 110 is too. The iconic vehicle has been re-imagined for 21st century adventure and its unparalleled off-roadability, as well as its robust interior,
前往Sonos.com，从现在起到11月27日或售完即止，精选产品最高可享75折优惠。SmartLess的听众们，让我向你们介绍一下Defender 110（卫士110）。你已准备好迎接迎面而来的任何挑战。Defender 110同样如此。这款标志性的车型为21世纪的冒险进行了重新设计，其无与伦比的越野性能，以及坚固的内饰，
are invaluable whether you're headed towards uncharted territory or just a weekend of exploration. The Defender 110 tackles challenging surroundings with absolute confidence. The SUV conveys strength outside and in, featuring peerless technology like intuitive driver display and an award-winning infotainment system to keep you connected no matter where the journey takes you. Adventure is unique to everyone and so is the defender. Choose from the two-door defender 90, the four-door defender 110, or the larger defender 130 with the ability to seat up to eight passengers, you'll find uncompromising performance in all three. Pack up and go even further with a Defender 110. Learn more at landroberusa.com forward slash Defender.
无论你是驶向未知的领域，还是仅仅进行周末的探索，它们都具有无法估量的价值。Defender 110以绝对的自信应对充满挑战的环境。这款SUV由内而外散发着力量感，配备了无与伦比的技术，如直观的驾驶员显示屏和屡获殊荣的信息娱乐系统，无论旅程将你带向何方，都能让你保持连接。冒险对每个人来说都是独一无二的，卫士也是如此。从两门版的Defender 90、四门版的Defender 110，到能够容纳多达八名乘客的更大尺寸的Defender 130中进行选择，你将在所有三款车型中找到毫不妥协的性能。开上Defender 110，打包出发，去得更远。访问landroberusa.com/defender了解更多信息。
All right, back to the show. I want to know, speaking of all these little things, take out what's it like, like you seem, I don't, we don't know each other that well, we met once and it was like a such a highlight of, you know, my life meeting, I'm such a huge fan, I've seen all your other that well, we met once, and it was like such a highlight of, you know, my life meeting, I'm such a huge fan, I've seen all your movies, I love JoJo Rabbit,
好了，回到节目中。我想知道，说到所有这些小事，塔伊卡，感觉是怎样的，我觉得，我们其实没那么熟，我们只见过一次，那简直是我生命中的高光时刻，能见到你，我是你的超级粉丝，我看过你所有的其他——没那么熟，我们只见过一次，那简直是我生命中的高光时刻，能见到你，我是你的超级粉丝，我看过你所有的电影，我太喜欢《乔乔兔》了，
I've seen it like three times. And... Tyka has no recollection. No, of course not. I remember I almost put your jacket on, do you remember that? I remember that. It was a great time.
我大概看了有三遍吧。而且……塔伊卡完全没有印象。不，当然没有。我记得我差点把你的夹克穿走了，你还记得吗？我记得。那是一段美好的时光。
It was a highlight for me as well. Okay, so, no, like so what, the little bit I know of you, you seem completely relaxed, low, key, chill, like normal, down to earth. What do you do? He just mentioned he's married, by the way, so just fucking cool it.
对我来说这也是个高光时刻。好吧，所以，不，我就觉得，根据我对你有限的了解，你看起来完全放松、低调、随性、冷静，就像个正常人，脚踏实地。你平时都做些什么？他刚才顺便提到他已经结婚了，所以麻烦你他妈的冷静点。
What do you do when you meet a personality that's totally opposite of yours, that you have to work with, you're like, oh my God, this guy or this girl's way too much for me. They're not on my level. How do you deal with that? Um, I just, I just bitch about them later. You send all your notes in through the first AD.
当你遇到一个性格跟你截然相反，又不得不一起工作的人时，你会怎么做？你会想，哦天哪，这家伙或这个女孩对我的冲击实在太大了。他们根本不在我的水平线上。你该如何处理这种情况？嗯，我，我只会事后在背后吐槽他们。你把所有的意见都通过第一副导演转达。
Yeah. And then I got home and this son of a bitch. I believe this guy. Um, this way we'll do that. Yeah. I mean, actors in particular, just hard work. And then each actor's got a different way of working that you got to find out because they won't tell you and you got to figure it out by watching them and you're like, oh, you got them. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're one of them. And then there's all the other
对。然后我回到家，心想这个王八蛋。我真服了这个家伙。嗯，平时我们就会这么干。对。我的意思是，尤其是演员，真的很难搞。而且每个演员都有不同的工作方式，你必须去摸索，因为他们不会主动告诉你，你只能通过观察他们来找出答案，然后你就会想，哦，我拿捏住你了。对，对，对。你是那种类型的。然后还有所有其他
ones that are, let's do an in-protection. Oh No, they take a one for me now, right? Yeah, yeah, and those guys who like Talk about this a lot with crew loves that they go Let's do an in-protection like all right like are you at the point though in your career where you're just like you know I'm gonna hand pick the people I want the actors Just people you trust and you're friends.
类型的，比如“我们再拍一条做备份吧”。哦。不，他们现在会为我拍一条备份，对吧？对，对，而且那些人，剧组人员非常喜欢经常谈论这个，他们会说“我们再拍一条做备份吧”，就像是，好吧，就像是——不过，你的职业生涯是不是已经到了这种地步，就是你觉得，你知道的，我要亲自挑选我想要的人，挑选演员，只选那些你信任的、熟悉的朋友。
But what are we going to say to that guy? You're a bad improviser. You know, you fucking roll the camera and then there, you know, a lot of actors idea of improvising with ad libbing is just say the first thing that comes into your head doesn't have to help the scene at all or anything. They go, actually, cool wall. Yeah. seen it all or anything, they go, actually go cool wall. Yeah.
但是我们要对那个家伙说什么呢？你是个糟糕的即兴表演者。你知道的，你他妈的开机拍摄，然后有些演员对即兴表演和自由发挥的理解，就是把脑子里想到的第一句话说出来，完全不需要对推进剧情有任何帮助，或者诸如此类。他们会说：“其实，这堵墙挺酷的。”完全不需要对推进剧情有任何帮助，或者诸如此类。他们会说：“其实，这堵墙挺酷的。”
And then you're like fantastic. Well done. All right. That was the one for you. Let's move on. All right. Or it's just a list of jokes that 100% wrote the night before. All right.
然后你就会想：太棒了。干得漂亮。好啦。那一条就是为你拍的。我们继续吧。好吧。或者这只是一堆他们前一天晚上百分之百写好的笑话。好吧。
Ian Morris texted me out of the blue today just so I can get a mention on E.S. who Ian, who co-wrote next goal wins. He's our mutual friend. And. So that's. Sorry, so it's about soccer, yeah. And Willie, what do you play in the film? Nothing, I have it.
伊恩·莫里斯今天突然给我发了条短信，这样他就能在《SmartLess》里被提及了。伊恩是《下一球进球》的联合编剧。他是我们的共同好友。而且。所以就是这样。抱歉，所以这部电影是关于足球的，对吧。威利，你在电影里扮演什么角色？没什么，我没有。
I can't mean. Take a ask me last minute to come in and just do a couple days to help out. But. A small, small little role. Yeah. But he makes a huge difference. The film is about the, it's a true story about the worst soccer team in the world,
我不能算。塔伊卡最后一分钟叫我去客串一下，花了两天时间去帮忙。但是。一个很小很小的角色。对。但他的作用太大了。这部电影讲述的是一个真实的故事，关于世界上最糟糕的足球队，
which is the American Samoan soccer team. And in the history of the country, they'd never won a game or scored a goal. Wow. And I think like in 2001 or something, they suffered the biggest international loss, which is still the record today, which was against Australia, and they
也就是美属萨摩亚足球队。在那个国家历史上，他们从来没有赢过一场比赛，甚至没有进过一个球。哇。而且我觉得大概在2001年左右，他们遭遇了国际比赛中最惨痛的失利，这个纪录至今仍然保持着，那是对阵澳大利亚的比赛，他们
lost 31 nil. Jesus. Let's figure that out. What does that, a goal every three minutes? Was anybody in the goal? Was there a goal tender? He was going in the goal. I think he was quite traumatized by that.
以0比31惨败。天哪。我们来算算。那是什么概念，每三分钟进一个球？当时有人守门吗？有守门员吗？当时守门员在球门里。我觉得他当时被那一战严重创伤了。
And they lost to the Sakharoaru, who is not the best soccer team in the world. But, but DC. And then they got this coach in Thomas Rongen. They, I think you might have been the only person who responded to the, to the request. He came into the island and got them in shape and then they ended up spoiling it. They scored a goal. Yeah. Yeah. And it was a big and that person, the guy playing that part is Michael Fassbender, who is a fantastic dude. That man is gifted. Really an actor.
而且他们输给了“袋鼠军团”，这可不是世界上最好的足球球队。但是，但是DC。然后他们迎来了这位教练托马斯·龙根。我想他可能是唯一一个回应这个请求的人。他来到岛上让他们恢复体态，然后他们最终创造了奇迹。他们进了一个球。对。对。那是一个非常重要的时刻，扮演那个角色的人是迈克尔·法斯宾德，他是个绝佳的家伙。那家伙太有天赋了。真的是个好演员。
And it was funny because he's done so many serious, really heavy. He's got a new series movie coming out next to him as well. He's someone you can improve for us. He's very good. He's a a new series movie coming out next to him soon as well. He's someone you can him for us. He's very good. He's a smart dude. He's so good in the killer too, the venture film. It's fantastic. I want to see that too.
这很有趣，因为他演过那么多严肃的、非常沉重的角色。他接下来还有一部新剧要上映。他也是那种你可以跟他进行即兴发挥的演员。他非常棒。他是个聪明的家伙。他在大卫·芬奇的电影《杀手》里也演得太棒了。这部电影太赞了。我也想看那部。
I want to see that too. But anyway, and so you have fast bender in there in a very sort of like comedic role. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Right? And I didn't think it would be that his role would become his comeder. I thought that everyone else around him would provide the comedy. But he was just, he kept delivering and just gave him more things to do.
我也想看那部。但不管怎样，所以你在片中让法斯宾德出演了一个非常具有喜剧色彩的角色。嗯哼。对吧？而且我本来以为他的角色不会是负责搞笑的。我以为他周围的其他所有人会承包喜剧效果。但他一直在不断地产出绝佳表现，所以我忍不住给他加了更多戏份。
Yeah. Was it, was it, was it twisting arms to get him in that film? Because, you know, he's, he's much more interested in racing cars right now. Is it a race car driver? Yeah. Yeah. He was doing that when I called him up. He was, he had to fit it in in between races. Yeah, he's there.
对。当时，当时，当时是不是费了一番周折才让他答应出演那部电影？因为，你知道的，他现在对赛车更有兴趣。他是个赛车手吗？对。对。我打电话给他时他正在赛车。他必须在两场比赛的间隙把这部电影拍完。对，他就在那儿。
Well, I'm thinking about taking the year off and just racing. He's legit. He's legit, but I said, well, that's in Hawaii. And he said, I'll be there. Yeah. Yeah. He's got this love. He's got the fast bitters.
好吧，我正在考虑休息一年专门去赛车。他是认真的。他是认真的，但我说，地点在夏威夷。他说，我会准时到的。对。对。他有着这种热情。他真不愧是法斯宾德。
He's got one of the, like, the more you ask him about what's going on in his life, the cooler it is, because he's like, yeah, I mean, while racing this type of BMW, then I race this kind of thing, and then where's that? Well, we drove, we're in Portugal, and then we drove up to, fuck, Belgium to do that thing, and you're like,
他有那种，你越是追问他最近的生活在忙什么，就觉得越酷，因为他会说：“对，我当时在开这种宝马赛车，然后我又去开那种车，接着去哪儿了？哦，我们在葡萄牙，然后我们开车去了，见鬼，比利时去参加那个活动，”然后你会觉得，
what kind of life is this? This is a fucking life, I'm not. This is real Steve McQueen life. Yeah, it's a real Steve McQueen life. Like, cool. This channel of that whole life, he's Steve McQueen life. Yeah, it's a real Steve McQueen like cool channeled that whole life. He's stolen that whole life. He raised Le Mans. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
这过的是什么神仙日子？这他妈才是人生啊，我可没。这才是真正的史蒂夫·麦奎因式的生活。对，这才是真正的史蒂夫·麦奎因式的生活。太酷了。简直是把那种生活方式复刻了下来，他就是史蒂夫·麦奎因。他参加过勒芒赛。对，对，对。
Fucking a tiger. What how much time do you spend in New Zealand versus the states? Depending on what text department is sure, sure. It changes. It changes. It changes. It changes. It changes like a horse.
他妈的，塔伊卡。你花在新西兰的时间和在美国的时间大概各占多少？这取决于部门在做什么，当然，当然。这会变的。这会变的。这会变的。这会变的。就像一匹马一样在变。
How you should have said it in a number of days, I can stand each place. And you do the right one for each one of those, for sure. Yeah, yeah. I have about 14 days left this year in the States. I bring Siri. Wow, really? I'm a serious. Well, you've time.
你应该用具体的天数来回答，你在每个地方能呆多久。而且你每次都要给出完全契合的回答，真的。对，对。我今年在美国大概还剩下14天。我带了Siri。哇，真的吗？我是认真的。好吧，你有时间。
I'm going to get out of here. Yeah. Yeah. But, uh, no, I just, I try to spend a lot of time in New Zealand because my kids are there and, uh, I'm just to get out of here. Yeah. But I just feel, I try to spend a lot of time in New Zealand, because my kids are there and I'm just trying to come here because I want to see Will. Are they going to love this movie? Are they soccer fans? No, they don't care about soccer.
我要离开这里了。对。对。但是，呃，不，我只是，我尽量多花点时间在新西兰，因为我的孩子们在那里，呃，我只是想离开这里。对。但我只是觉得，我尽量多花点时间在新西兰，因为我的孩子们在那里，我来这里只是因为我想见见威尔。他们会喜欢这部电影吗？他们是球迷吗？不，他们根本不在乎足球。
New Zealand is not a soccer country. No, it's rugby, right? It's rugby. It's all rugby. Are you a rugby fan? I'm a massive rugby fan. Really? We just went to the World Cup games. I just saw that. World Cup and just tell you how they go. How did they do? We just went to the World Cup games. I just saw that World Cup and just...
新西兰可不是个足球国家。不，是橄榄球，对吧？是橄榄球。全都是橄榄球。你是橄榄球迷吗？我是个超级橄榄球迷。真的吗？我们刚刚去看了世界杯的比赛。我刚看到那个。世界杯，然后跟你讲讲他们的情况。他们战绩如何？我们刚刚去看了世界杯的比赛。我刚看到那个世界杯，然后就……
I watched that. Tell you how they do. We got to the final and then we lost. Barely lost. To South Africa. To South Africa. You guys are the two powerhouses, right? Yeah.
我看过那个。跟你讲讲他们表现。我们打进了决赛，然后输了。惜败。输给了南非。输给了南非。你们俩是南半球的两大豪强，对吧？对。
Well, hang on. The spring box, South Africa, barely beat England. Let's be honest. They were kind of charmed this tournament. Yeah. And, and New Zealand had a really good chance, uh, to win a good chance. We often, it's, it's always close between those teams. Did you ever play rugby as a kid?
好吧，等等。跳羚队，也就是南非队，勉强赢了英格兰。说实话。他们在这次锦标赛中有点像是有神仙庇佑。对。而且，新西兰队其实有很好的机会，呃，有很好的机会赢得比赛。我们经常，这两支球队之间的对决总是难分伯仲。你小时候踢过橄榄球吗？
I played rugby up until my sort of late 20s. I mean, you can, you, it really hurts, doesn't it? There's no padding. It's still, I get up in the morning and like sometimes this, you know, an ankle won't work or a knee won't work. Well, there's little injuries you get in your 20s and your bounce back, where it's fast and now it's like your body, then your body just punishes you later. Some people say that it's safer to tackle in that sport because there's no helmets.
我一直打橄榄球到快三十岁左右。我的意思是，你，你会，这真的很疼，不是吗？没有任何护具。到现在，我早上起床有时会发现，你知道，脚踝不听使唤了，或者膝盖不听使唤了。这就是你在二十多岁时受的那些小伤，当时恢复得很快，但现在，这就变成了你的身体在日后对你的惩罚。有人说那个运动的擒抱其实更安全，因为没有头盔。
You're actually a little bit more careful. We don't tackle with your head. Over here, they just just dive through the air with their head first, trying to stab people with the head. There's over here, they just sort of just just like just dive through the air with the head first. Yeah, trying to stab people with their bodies. Well, when the CTE stories were all about in the last five, 10 years or something like that, there was a thought that maybe NFL would think about removing the helmets.
你其实会更加小心。你们不会用头去撞人。而在美国的橄榄球里，他们只是直接飞身跃起用头部率先冲撞，试图用脑袋去戳人。这里，他们只是飞身跃起用头部率先冲撞。对，试图用身体去戳人。好吧，当过去五、十年左右关于CTE（慢性创伤性脑病）的新闻铺天盖地时，当时有一种想法认为NFL可能会考虑取消头盔。
Really? Yes, so that people would stop using their head as part of the tackle. And all the other pads would still be on. You just have to learn how to just tackle differently, like the folks play rugby. Yeah, you just tackle and move your head out of the way. Are they really less than rugby, the CTE? It seems like they have less questions.
真的吗？对，这样大家就不会再用脑袋去进行冲撞了。而且其他护具都还留着。你只需要学会如何用不同的方式去冲撞，就像打橄榄球的人那样。对，你只要冲撞然后把头避开就行了。橄榄球引发的CTE真的比这个少吗？感觉他们的疑问要少一些。
Less concussion. Less concussion. Wow, that's kind of amazing. Because you don't have that false sense of safety. Yeah, you protect yourself. Don't make sure your head doesn't bang in anything. That's interesting. Mm-hmm.
脑震荡更少。脑震荡更少。哇，那真是太神奇了。因为你没有那种虚假的安全感。对，你要保护好自己。确保你的头不会撞到任何东西。这很有意思。嗯。
All right. So, Tyka, hi. What about like, when you're directing something? Tyka, each time he told me, he said, hi. Hi. As if this might be usable for the first part of the industry. Sure, forget. We're not even in this. We may cut him, but it's starting before this.
好吧。那么，维佳，嗨。导演的时候是什么样的？维佳，每次他都跟我说，嗨。嗨。就好像这能用在节目的前半部分一样。当然，忘了。我们根本没聊这个。我们可能会剪掉这部分，但它是从这之前开始的。
Yeah, we are. I'm sorry. So, it's like, um, great answer. So, it's guess is take away TT, take away, welcome. Hey, take a question about your process. Uh, the, when you, uh, are directing something, is, is there an itch to be in it always? Are you like, oh, God, I'm so glad I'm not in this. No, I really love being in it.
对，我们是的。我很抱歉。所以，就像是，呃，回答得真好。所以，这大概是去掉TT，去掉，欢迎。嘿，问一个关于你的创作过程的问题。呃，当你，呃，在执导某个作品时，是不是总有一种想亲自参演的冲动？还是你会觉得，哦，天哪，我真庆幸自己没演这个。不，我真的很喜欢参演。
I love, I love acting. I think it's fun, but only if it's something that I find fun. And I've got control over that. Do you like the process of directing yourself, the fact that you don't, you do it? Yeah, well, I like it because it's easy if we did direct people in the scene as well. I can talk straight to them while I'm doing the lines. Yeah, do it.
我喜欢，我喜欢演戏。我觉得这很有趣，但前提是我觉得它有趣，而且我有掌控权。你喜欢导演自己的过程吗，也就是你亲自这么做这件事？对，嗯，我喜欢，因为如果在场景里我们也导演演员的话，那就很容易。我可以在说台词的同时直接跟他们交流。对，就这么做。
I do it in the lines. What if you have an actor that's not very pliable with all of that? Like, they get upset that you're talking to them in the middle of the scene that they want you to wait till after cut. You ever had one of those? It's pretty lucky I haven't worked with people like that. Yeah. Maybe one or two, but I just sort of tend to ignore it.
我就是在台词里这么干的。如果你遇到一个对所有这些都不太听指挥的演员怎么办？比如说，他们会因为你在他们演戏到一半时跟他们说话而生气，他们希望你等到导演喊“咔”之后再说。你遇到过这样的人吗？我很幸运，没有跟那种人合作过。对。也许有一两个吧，但我一般倾向于忽视他们。
Kind of kind of cut them out of the cool group and then just ignore them and then they go out and then pay the quit or just alienated and believe them on set. Yeah, I mean films, it's like high school. Do you have siblings that have cool names like you too? Yeah, most people have got cool names. My kids have got really cool names. My first daughter, her first name is DeKainga or DeHenika,
把他们从酷炫小团体里除名，然后直接无视他们，接着他们就会离开，要么放弃，要么就被孤立，然后在片场被晾在一边。对，我是说拍电影，这就跟高中一样。你们有没有像你们一样名字很酷的兄弟姐妹？对，大多数人的名字都很酷。我孩子们的名字非常酷。我的大女儿，她的名叫德凯恩卡（DeKainga）或德海妮卡（DeHenika），
which means house or home of the she-hawk. Wow. Yeah, and my second daughter, Matiwa, the literal translation is time of the dead. Wow, wow. That's awesome. Be careful what you name your kids. You know that that Sean's that Sean means I like macaroni? Yeah, so it's not a lot of people know that. Not a lot of people know that, but you could.
意思是雌鹰的房子或家。哇。对，我的二女儿，玛蒂娃（Matiwa），直译过来就是亡灵的时刻。哇，哇。太棒了。给孩子起名字可得小心。你知道肖恩（Sean）的意思是我喜欢通心粉吗？对，所以没多少人知道这一点。没多少人知道，不过你可以……
I like macaroni. That's the only if you spell it SEAN. You spell it SH AWN and we'll tell them what that means. That's Jason's improv. I like setups. I don't like punchlines. And you say the other part. You say the other part.
我喜欢通心粉。只有当你把名字拼写为 S-E-A-N 的时候才是这样。如果你把它拼写为 S-H-A-W-N，我们就告诉他们那是什么意思。那是杰森的即兴发挥。我喜欢铺垫。我不喜欢包袱。然后你来说另一部分。你来说另一部分。
Take an action. You've got a poem you wrote. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. Exactly.
采取行动。你写了一首诗。关于这个情况。关于这个情况。关于这个情况。关于这个情况。关于这个情况。没错。
Exactly. Tell them. Tell them what you wrote. Tell them what you wrote. and then point at the person. We did this fucking stupid bit for a long time. Ty could have were doing on the on taxing each other. And he was and we were doing flag means death. And there was a scene where we're res,
没错。告诉他们。告诉他们你写了什么。告诉他们你写了什么。然后指着那个人。我们这个该死的蠢段子玩了好久。维佳和我在互相开玩笑。当时我们在拍《我们的旗帜意味着死亡》。有个场景是这样的，我们重新……
Derby Reese has to walk away. And I said something to his character. And then Ty could come up by me and goes, Reese, Derby Reese has to walk away and I said something to his character and then it comes up by me and goes, don't man, let him, let him go, man, or something like this. But he said it in this like we were laughing because he was doing it on purpose to sound like it was like in an after school special. I mean, grab my arm like, just let him go, man. And so, just let him go, Johnny, we'll get him next year.
德比·里斯（Derby Reese）不得不走开。我对他的角色说了句话。然后维佳走到我身边说，里斯，德比·里斯不得不走开，我对他的角色说了句话，接着他走到我身边说，别这样，伙计，让他去吧，伙计，诸如此类的话。但他说话的语气就像——我们当时笑得不行，因为他是故意模仿那种放学后播出的教育特辑里的腔调。我的意思是，抓住我的胳膊说，就让他走吧，伙计，明年我们再收拾他。
And we started laughing. He's so fucking hard and everybody's like, what are you guys laughing about? And he kept going, don't worry about it, Johnny. They were never like us. We were always outside of this, Johnny. The fucking director was like, you guys got a fucking cool at man. And then we were texting each other these stupid things.
然后我们开始大笑。他笑得太特么厉害了，大家都问，你们在笑什么呢？他一直说，别担心，约翰尼。他们才从来不像我们。我们永远都是局外人，约翰尼。那个该死的导演说，你们俩真特么酷啊。然后我们就开始互发这些蠢兮兮的短信。
It's fun stuff, you know what I mean? Yeah, it sounds like a good time. It does sound like a good good. It's not funny anymore Johnny. People got hurt. We killed a kid, Johnny. It's not a game anymore. People are getting hurt. Fuck me, that gets me every time. Tyka, listen, this has been a pleasure. It's eight, it's after eight o'clock. After eight o'clock, it went pistol. You just got to fucking plane. No one wanted to do this at this hour.
这挺好玩的，你知道我的意思吗？对，听起来是个好时光。听起来确实是个好……这已经不好笑了，约翰尼。有人受伤了。我们害死了一个小孩，约翰尼。这不再是个游戏了。有人受伤了。操，每次听到这我都忍不住。维佳，听着，这太令人愉快了。现在是八点，已经过八点了。过八点了，都快歇了。你还得赶飞机呢。没人想在这个点干这个。
Are you kidding me? This is so much fun. What I saw you, it was all on. Sean's like, you're like, it's 30 minutes past the ice cream Sunday, right? How far are we past? You're not you're joking, but it's exactly what I'm going to do right now is I know. I'm not a part of what are you have?
你在开玩笑吗？这太有趣了。我看到你的时候，全都在状态。肖恩就像是，你就像是，距离吃冰淇淋圣代已经过去30分钟了，对吧？我们超出了多久？你不是在开玩笑，这正是我现在要做的，我知道。我不是……你有什么？
What's on your Sunday? What do you put vanilla ice cream chocolate syrup and whipped cream and I do a whole thing of hogging us. No, Jerry, because you start doing two scoops and you're like, well, there's only two scoops left. I might as well just finish you do the, you do the whole pint every single time. And let's see the proof of that. Go ahead, stand up, shake the cookie pouch.
你的圣代里有什么？你放香草冰淇淋、巧克力糖浆和鲜奶油，我一整桶都吃光。不，杰瑞，因为你开始吃两勺，然后你会想，反正只剩两勺了。我干脆把它吃完算了吧，你每次都把整整一品脱吃光。让我们看看证据。来吧，站起来，摇摇饼干袋。
Here it comes. There it is. Good for you. Hey, you know what I'd say? You're enjoying life. Yeah, absolutely right. We all have five minutes. Ty, get your fucking superstar, dude.
它来了。这不就来了。真有你的。嘿，你知道我想说什么吗？你在享受生活。对，完全正确。我们都有五分钟时间。维佳，你特么是个超级巨星，老兄。
Yeah, I love you, dude. I love you guys. Thank you so much, man. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you I love you guys. Thank you so much, man. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you. Yeah, exactly. Thanks for doing it right away.
对，我爱你们，老兄。我也爱你们，伙计们。非常感谢，老兄。谢谢你们做这个。谢谢，谢谢。我爱你们，伙计们。非常感谢，老兄。谢谢你们做这个。谢谢，谢谢。对，没错。谢谢你们马上就办。
You asked me if I'd do this about three years ago. I don't know. I'm really happy. I know you did. Listen, for the record, I would have recorded this with you at 9 p.m. Yeah. 10. 10.
你大概三年前就问过我会不会做这个。我不行。我真的很高兴。我知道你问过。听着，郑重声明，哪怕是晚上9点，我也会跟你录这个。对。10点。10点。
I could do better. Well, thank you for eventually doing it. I appreciate it. I'll see you next week. Thank you, Tyka. See you next week. Thanks, guys. Thanks, Tyka.
我可以表现得更好。好吧，谢谢你最终还是做了这件事。我很感激。我下周见。谢谢你，维佳。下周见。谢谢你们，伙计。谢谢你，维佳。
All right. Thanks, pal. Oh, thank you, Eddie. Well, you pulled it out of your hat there, Willie. I know. Yeah, I know. That was fantastic. So wait, now hang on a second.
好的。谢谢，老兄。哦，谢谢你，埃迪。嗯，你从帽子里把它掏出来了，威利。我知道。对，我知道。太棒了。等等，现在等一下。
That was our first official yawn. I think we've ever had in all of the time. No, you had one during the show that was quiet. It was quiet, yeah, but I hide it behind the microphone so the guest doesn't see it or my co-host don't see it. But we heard that one and so that is, that's an evening record right there with the yawn. Well, it's put it this way. And there's a belch. Good, thank you, Sean. It's 11 minutes after eight and I will be, I'll be asleep by 9.15. Yeah, And I will be, I'll be asleep by 915.
那是我们的第一个官方哈欠。我想要么是我们所有节目以来的第一次。不，你在节目期间打过一个，很安静。是很安静，对，但我把它藏在麦克风后面，这样嘉宾就看不到了，我的联合主持也看不到。但我们听到了那个哈欠，所以，这就是今晚的哈欠纪录了。好吧，这么说吧。还有个嗝。很好，谢谢你，肖恩。现在是八点十一分，我九点十五分前就会睡着。对，而且我，我九点十五分前就会睡着。
Yeah, I know. Yeah, I'll be asleep by 915. What are you gonna do? What are you gonna do right now, too, you're gonna bed? Right now, I'm gonna go up. I got a kid, the little kids, make sure that they're down. Going to sleep. Yeah.
对，我知道。对，我九点十五分前就会睡着。你打算怎么办？你现在打算干嘛，也是去睡觉吗？现在，我要上楼去了。我有个孩子，小孩子们，确保他们都睡下了。去睡觉。对。
Okay. I'm gonna go in there and see what's going on on MSNBC. Wonderful. You're gonna make a Sunday. I'm gonna make a Sunday and sit on the couch and get fat. So listen, Tyka, you're going to watch this old house? No, that's Sundays. I watch that Sunday. Yeah, that's Sundays with Sundays.
好的。我要去看看MSNBC那边在播什么。太棒了。你要做一个圣代。我要做一个圣代，坐在沙发上长胖。听着，维佳，你要看《老房子》吗？不，那是周日播的。我周日看那个。对，那是周日的节目。
You don't have a... Do you... Oh, that's so good. I know. Tyka, can I stay down? Scotty! Hey, Tyka, what were you watching tonight? Before we get... well, sorry,
你没有……你……哦，太好了。我知道。维佳，我可以留下来吗？斯科蒂！嘿，维佳，你今晚在看什么？在我们开始……好吧，抱歉，
yes, let's get into the tiger. How great is Ty? How funny and cool and radicy. Yeah, it seems very hip and cool and like, you know, he was hard to get on because he kept like, he was changing and then he was like, like two years ago, I was like, hey, will you do it? Like right when he came on my list too. Yeah, and I go Come to the podcast. Yeah, it's a great and then like Trying in this schedule and then he's always in like England and New Zealand and shooting stuff and whatever Me also just doesn't care in the best way No, he does that that sexy indifference, right? It's just like it's like well if it happens it happens if it doesn't it doesn't it's not Atlanta a few months ago this earlier this this year, and I get a text and I said,
是的，我们来聊聊泰。泰有多棒？多有趣、多酷、多特立独行。对，他看起来非常时髦、很酷，而且，你知道的，他很难请到，因为他一直……他当时在变动，然后大概在两年前，我就说，嘿，你愿意上节目吗？就像他刚上我的邀请名单时那样。对，我说来上播客吧。对，太棒了，然后就像是在他的日程里各种协调，他总是身在英国、新西兰，到处拍戏什么的。而且他也是那种用最好的方式毫不在乎的人。不，他有那种性感的冷漠感，对吧？就好像，嗯，如果发生了就发生了，如果没有就算了。几个月前在亚特兰大，今年早些时候，我收到一条短信，上面写着，
listen, you or your doppelganger, or either you or your doppelganger just walked into a restaurant in Atlanta and went upstairs. And then I walked downstairs and there he was on the ground floor with me. Where? In Atlanta. In Atlanta. It's recently? Yeah. was on the ground floor with where? Is it just in Atlanta? In Atlanta. Just recently? Yeah. Well, I know, a few months ago.
听着，要么是你，要么是你的替身，要么是你或者你的替身刚刚走进了亚特兰大的一家餐厅并上了楼。然后我走下楼，他就跟我一起在一楼。在哪？在亚特兰大。在亚特兰大。是最近吗？对。在哪个地方的一楼？在亚特兰大。就在最近吗？对。嗯，我知道，几个月前。
He's just such a fucking cool. And that's when he closed the deal for the, uh, Yeah, but that was one of the other times that he was like, yeah, I can't wait to do it. And then he's one of those, but he's one of those people too that kind of created his own style of comedy. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah, he doesn't have to, Jay, you said he doesn't ask for it.
他简直酷毙了。这就是他敲定……的交易的时候。是的，但那是他表现出“对，我迫不及待想做”的其他时刻之一。而且他也是那种开创了自己的喜剧风格的人。天哪。对。对，他不需要，杰伊，你说过他不强求。
He's created his own lane. A lane. Yeah, he's created his own lane. And he doesn't, you get this, it's true. You get this, he doesn't really, not that he doesn't care about what other people are doing. It's just that he's into what he's doing in a way,
他开辟了自己的道路。一条道路。对，他开辟了自己的道路。而且他并不——你懂的，确实如此。你明白的，他其实并不是——倒不是说他不在乎别人在做什么。只是他以某种方式全身心投入到他正在做的事情中，
and he's confident about it. He's super smart and super funny and self-deprecating, and all of those kind of great things. But it seems like he's more concerned in the best way about making himself proud and making himself laugh than other people and other people's opinions or their ability to get what he's doing doesn't really guide what he's doing. No, he's genuinely just literally sent me a text talking. He's a sweet thoughtful person.
并且对此充满自信。他超级聪明、超级有趣、懂得自嘲，具备所有这些极好的特质。但感觉他以最好的方式更关心的是让自己骄傲、让自己发笑，而不是别人以及别人的意见，或者别人是否能理解他在做什么，并不能真正左右他的行为。不，他真的是发短信跟我说。他是个温柔体贴的人。
Yeah, he seems like that. And you know what, these days, those kind of people, they're hard to come these these days those kind of people they're hard to come BYE WONDERFUL BYE Smart Smart Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco.
对，他看起来就是这样。你知道吗，如今这种人，现在这种人很难遇到了。再见！太棒了！再见！Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔伯科100%有机手工打造的。
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen Smart, less. than the holidays. Joyous! Did you say joyous? There is nothing joyous about Christmas. Anyways... I have such great memories with my family decorating, listening to holiday music and watching Christmas movies. Sounds like a lot of noise, noise, noise to me! Oh, hey, well, he's already interrupted my interest so I guess I can reveal our next guest. The Grinch, anything you want to tell our listeners?
我们的下一集将在一个星期后发布，你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，或者你可以在节假日收听Smartless。快乐！你刚才说快乐吗？圣诞节可一点也不快乐。总之……我和家人在装饰、听节日音乐以及看圣诞电影时有那么多美好的回忆。在我听来，这全都是噪音、噪音、噪音！哦，嘿，好吧，他已经打断了我的兴致，所以我想我可以揭晓我们的下一位嘉宾了。格林奇，有什么想对我们的听众说的吗？
Well, yes, actually, I have a new podcast. From Wondery, Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show is a pathetic attempt by the people of Rubil to use my situation as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch. Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas gear, grilliesing celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire.
好吧，是的，实际上，我有了一个新播客。来自万得的《格林奇假日脱口秀》是维尔维尔（Rubil）人民的一个可悲尝试，他们想利用我的遭遇作为一次寓教于乐的机会。所以加入我吧，格林奇。听我发起一场反对圣诞装备的运动，像火炉上的栗子一样炙烤明星嘉宾。
Your family will love the show. As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你的家人会喜欢这个节目的。如你所知，我对小孩子一向是出了名的好。在万得应用上或在你获取播客的任何地方关注《格林奇假日脱口秀》。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。